Ist das der aktuelle PogChamp?
Also Kripp war bisher der beste PogChamp Ich weiß man darf das 2021 eigentlich gar
nicht mehr fragen aber ist das ein Grill? Oder ist das ein Kerl der aussieht wie ein Grill?
Wenn mir nicht, dann sicher. Aber nicht dass jetzt, ich bin jetzt ruhig, nicht dass wieder
30 Spiele an Leute getriggert sind. Habe ich nur gerade gefragt wo ich das neue PogChamp
im Auto gesehen habe. So ich muss mal gucken ob der PreisChamp gestern Nacht noch gedidost
wurde? Oder noch weiter gedidost wurde? Ey sieht nicht so aus. Kein PreisChamp-Didost
mehr. Das war gestern Abend schon ein bisschen auffällig oder? Guck mal, Network Traffic
by Packets gestern Abend im Stream. Boom. Richtig. Boom. Danach ist weg. Boom bickshack.
Da gab es schon ordentlich viele Packages. 0W. Gar nicht auffällig zu dem Zeitpunkt
hier. Ich habe gestern Abend kein Cloudflare mehr in der Port gepackt. Das war mir schon
zu spät. Ich bin am Pennen gegangen. Aber das geht ja schnell, weil ich habe ja Cloudflare
schon vom normalen davor. Und ja passt schon. Mach mal dann. Ich glaube das mache ich nach
dem Stream. Und heute Mittag basteln wir noch ein bisschen PreisChamp weiter. Max bin stiller
Schuhschauer. Ich kann heute Morgen nicht. Stiller Schuhschauer seit 2042. Ja nice.
So dass ihr alle am Start seid. Du schaffst nicht viele Leute im Stream darauf zugreifen.
Du schaffst nicht das Default Connection Limit im Linux Kernel zu erreichen. Innerhalb von
paar Minuten. Das kriegst du bei Zuschauern im Stream nicht hin. Das ist ein 16. Dazu
kommt auch noch. Es ist ja nicht so als braucht er für eine Anfrage 5 Sekunden oder so. Das
ist ein 16 Core. Die Seite ist in. Wir gucken mal wie schnell die Seite lädt. Guck mal,
das ist instant da. Okay wir machen mal Reload. Oh je. Es geht los Leute. Guck mal wie schnell
die Seite lädt. Bam. Hier. Okay der braucht erstmal die Seite und dann lädt er das ganze
die ganzen Daten. Okay der braucht eine halbe Sekunde aus dem Cache. Und warum der so lang?
Macht der da 3 Stunden? Kann man das irgendwie sehen was der da so lang lädt? Warum lädt
er eine Aboutpage? Vielleicht sollte ich die Routen mal deregistrieren die ich gar nicht
mehr brauche. Hier lädt er schnell und ab da lädt er langsam. Okay das ist der User
Counter. Ach wisst ihr was die Seite fühlt sich schnell an. Der Rest ist mir egal. Bam.
Who cares. Die Leute sind Youtube gewöhnt. Guckt euch mal an wie lange das dauert bis
Youtube fertig offen ist. Seht ihr das? Wenn du Youtube Reloadest. Alter. Wie viel Last
verursachen die Websocket? Pro Verbindung so gut wie gar nichts. Das Problem ist glaube
ich eher wenn der nachdem ich die Anwendung ändere irgendwie 20.000 Verbindungen erstmal
abbauen will aber keine Ahnung. Cloudflare gut und Ruhe ist dann. Weil wenn es danach
noch Probleme gibt weiß ich auf jeden Fall es liegt an mir. Fehler gefunden. Was für
ein Fehler? Achja by the way wir können mal ausprobieren. Chrome, Lighthouse, Benchmark
oder so. Es gab doch ein Google Website Benchmark. Guck mal was der meint. Page Speed. Mal kurz
hier den Dark wieder raus. Das kann man ich weiß man kann es auch in der Konsole machen
aber man backt es in der Konsole manchmal. Ich zeig es euch gleich. Das backt bei mir
in der Konsole rum. Weil es irgendwie erstmal die Fehlermeldung bekommt dass JavaScript
nicht aktiviert ist. Muss ich mal gucken. Aber wir machen mal Analyse hier. What? Zehn
Sieg. Was machen die da alle? Das ist doch easy. Das ist doch instant da. Okay ich verstehe
es nicht. Hä? Wie zehn Sekunden? GT Matrix. Hab ich doch.
Hab ich schon nicht benutzt. Okay. Wow. Alter. Was ist das für eine Seite? Hackermans am
Start. Ja. Ja. Ja. Da ist er. Der Preis Jam. Ah. Okay. Letzterlich man kann sich absolut
darauf verlassen. Es ist komplett random. Aber es ist komplett random einfach nur. Warum
braucht er zwei Sekunden das zu laden? Das dauert 500 Millisekunden easy. Und dann braucht
es genau 500 Millisekunden ungefähr bis die Seite da ist. Was auch immer. So jetzt machen
wir uns ein paar Videos angucken. Aber es ist nochmal Lighthouse in den Developer Tools.
Aber Desktop. Generate Report. Guck da backt der rum weil er auf die Seite. Ach nee jetzt
funktioniert es. Hä? Ich hab das vorhin ausprobiert. Nee genau. Sorry. Und da ist jetzt alles gut
auf einmal. Leute ich. Man muss es nicht verstehen. Ich gehe auf die Seite drauf die ich schnell
mache. Das reicht mir ehrlich gesagt. Da gibt es ja auch nichts was wirklich langsam
ist. Da gibt es ja auch da gibt es ja auch nichts wirklich was langsam ist. Der liefert
ein bisschen. Der liefert ein paar Javascript Dinger aus. Und das Ding ist ja auch nicht
groß. Ganz ehrlich ich mache die Seite bei mir auf und es geht easy as fuck schnell also
scheiß drauf. Ob ich das von irgendeinem CTN aus liefere oder von meinem Hetzer Server
macht noch bald. Das sind wie groß ist die Seite? 30 Kilo Byte oder so. Macht doch überhaupt
keinen Unterschied. Ah doch doch doch es macht einen Unterschied. Weil das von der
jeweiligen hoffe ich mal zumindest wenn man das richtige CTN nimmt von näher ausgeliefert
wird von der jeweiligen Location wo der jeweilige Typ sitzt. Das Problem ist nur das Frontend
an sich bringt dir nichts weil er sich zur Hetzer Cloud verbinden muss für die ganzen
Daten also sprich du kriegst dann halt die Überschrift schneller. Da hast du es dann
voll von ja. So was empfiehlt uns YouTube denn heute? Es waren nicht so viele gute Videos
dabei und ich habe auch mal in meine History geguckt. War auch nichts die letzte Woche
so wirklich viel geiles dabei wo ich dachte es muss man unbedingt gucken. Ich habe ja
auf meinem Tablet einen extra Account gemacht mit dem ich YouTube gucke wo ich dann immer
meine History schauen kann und in Watchlater was ich mir markiert habe für kann man im
Stream gucken. Also eine Sache die mich persönlich jetzt interessiert weil ich mich schon nicht
mit beschäftigt habe ist das. Dieses Video fangen wir auch mal damit an. So es gibt nämlich
einen neuen Raspberry Pi der aber gar kein richtiger Raspberry Pi ist sondern eher so
eine Art Arduino habe ich gelesen. Mal gucken. Mal gucken ob sich das lohnt ihr wisst ja
dass ich schon viel mit ESP32 und ESP86 gebastelt habe auch im Stream. Mal gucken was das Ding
ist. Ich gehe mal davon aus dass auf diesem Ding hier ist er das? Ne. Das ist er. Ich
gehe mal davon aus ey das könnte mein Arm sein. Da könnten die Leute wieder schreiben
dass der Max hat dicke Arme. Das könnte ich sein. Bloß meine Fingerlegeln sind kürzer.
Meine Fingerlegeln sind ja quasi nicht existent. Das hat ungefähr die Größe von eher so einem
Arduino Nano oder sowas würde ich sagen. Gucken wir mal. Gucken wir mal ob das. Und
vor allem mit was man es programmiert. Ich habe ja da so eine Vermutung welche Programmiersprache
es sein könnte mit der man das programmiert aber. Lass wir uns mal überraschen. Der kann
MicroPython C++. Ach du Scheiße. Muss es echt immer C++ sein. Yo was geht? Das steht
und fällt damit ob das Ding WLAN hat oder nicht. Controller ohne WLAN kannst du ja nur
nochmal äußerst beschränkt in so ein Heimprojekt. Kein WLAN. Ja ok aber ohne WLAN ist es doch
sinnlos. Genau läuft nämlich kein Linux drauf. Das ist eher so eine Art Arduino.
Ja aber ohne WLAN? Warum? Was meint ihr denn warum die ganzen ESP Dinger so erfolgreich
sind weil die WIFI on Board haben. Und es wird mal Zeit dass die endlich ein 5GHz WLAN
Ding rausbringen. Ich glaube die Lautstärke passt jetzt oder? Mal gucken wie man es programmiert
ob man es für Plattformen auch programmieren kann und wie es gemacht ist. Ok der Preis
ist schonmal ok. Klar gibt es das noch billiger. Man kriegt in China ein ESP 2866 für keine
Ahnung. Was kosten die eigentlich mittlerweile bei Ali? Was habe ich jetzt angeklickt? Was
habe ich jetzt angeklickt Leute? Ich will das alles nicht haben. Geh fort AliExpress.
Was kosten die kleinen dann eigentlich mittlerweile bei AliExpress? Ok geht 50 Cent ok ok ok.
Alter ja. Ok die sind nochmal eine Ecke günstiger. Die gehen so ab einem Euro oder so los. Ich
meine der kostet halt 4. Aber naja. Mal gucken was er für Vorteile hat.
Warte mal was sieht man denn hier drauf? Zeig mal her. Ich muss mir mal ein Bild von dem
Board angucken. Pi Pico Board. Angucken was da alles drauf ist. Ok ist schonmal nicht beschriftet.
Das sackt ein bisschen. Das ist jetzt zu viel verlangt da mal irgendwie zumindest eine Pin
nochmal drüber zu schreiben oder wie? Ok das ist doof dass es nicht beschriftet ist. Schauen
wir mal hier. Der Unterseite. Also was haben wir denn für Anschlüsse? Gut das hier ist
zum irgendwo draufklipsen oder so ein USB. Debug. Was auch immer. Jede Menge GPIOs.
SPI, I2C. Zwei Stück wie es aussieht. Ne doch. Kann man für unterschiedliche Zwecke finden.
Zwei I2Cs haben wir. Zwei SPI. Zwei serielle Connection. Ne eins zwei. Zwei serielle Connections.
Zwei Digital Analog Konverter. Zwei Stück. Wenn ich das richtig sehe scheißt das auch
IO mäßig gegen einen ESP32 massiv ab. Ok das hier ist ganz praktisch. Aber da hat man
gleich Referenzwert für den I2C zum Kalibrieren oder sowas. Naja aber irgendwie weiß nicht
warum sollte man das verwenden? Warum? Ich kann einfach Retro Games auch auf was viel
stärkerem spielen. Ich mein Retro Games werden ja nicht mehr Retro dadurch dass sie auf
langsame Hardware laufen. Man kann Retro Games einfach auf schneller Hardware laufen lassen
und es geht trotzdem. Nein ist es nicht. Das ist quasi der Media Markt in Coconaland oder
was ist Micro Center? Hell yeah. Genau. So sieht es aus.
Was ist das? Achso. Gibt es irgendjemand der bei der ARM CPU Benamung durchblickt? Ich
check das nicht. Was sagt mir denn ein M0 Plus? Gibt es doch ein A8 und sowas? Ich
blicke da nicht durch. Das ist mir zu hoch. Ok was hat er denn? Dual Core 133. Das ist
so ungefähr in Richtung ESP32. Der hat zwar Dual Core 240 aber das ist unterschiedliche
Architektur. Das kann man nicht so genau vergleichen. 264kb RAM. Das ist gar nicht mal so schlecht.
260kb RAM ist gar nicht schlecht dafür. 2MB Flash für Firmware ist auch ok. Versus 4
was so default ist beim ESP32. Das ist beides in Ordnung. 26 dpi ist mehr als ausreichend.
Ja das reicht auch alles. Temperature Sensor. Ok das ist ganz nice aber Temperature Sensor
on Board bringt ja nicht so viel. Willst du ja Temperature Sensor der irgendwo neben dran
hängt. Ok ich gebe mir mal ein bisschen vor. Ich will mal wissen wie man den Kram programmiert.
Ok irgendwas was kein Mensch braucht. Auch keiner. Ich werde die Pico Micro USB Kabel
anbieten. Was cool wir hätten sie dem Ding mal einen HDMI Ausgang spendiert. Micro Controller
mit HDMI Ausgang gibt es so gut wie keine. Ist auch nicht so easy. Aber das wäre cool
oder zumindest ein VGA. Das wäre irgendwie ein halbwegs coolen Video Output wo man auch
was größeres dran anschließen kann. Das wäre schon mal ein Cellular. Bildschirm abfilm
in 2021. Ok es ist C++ geschätzt. Das ist CMake Output. Und warum genau soll ich das
verwenden versus einen ESP32. Oder gegen einen STM32 oder sowas. Also warum. Ok der Vorteil
hat sich mir jetzt gerade noch nicht zu 100% erschlossen. Vielleicht ist ja die Entwicklungsumgebung
und Libraries richtig cool. Aber ganz im Ernst auch wenn C++ eine absolute Kack Sprache ist,
die Sache mit Plattform IO und so ist relativ angenehm. Sofern man sich nicht mit C++ auseinandersetzen
muss mehr als nötig. C++ ist halt einfach eine absolute Zumutung pur. Warum ja man weiß
es nicht. Also aktuell verstehe ich die Daseinsberechtigung nicht so ganz. Warum man das braucht. Vielleicht
haben die bei der Raspberry Pi Foundation festgestellt, dass gerade im Heimbereich immer
mehr Leute anfangen mit Microcontroller programmieren und Sachen damit zu basteln. Da wollen sie
was von ab. Aber warum baut man das ohne WLAN. WLAN ist doch das wichtigste was du im Heimbereich
brauchst. Ansonsten kannst du halt irgendwelche Geräte steuern oder so. Aber du brauchst für
alles irgendwelche Connection. ESP gibt es mit VGA. Ernsthaft. Was zur. What the. Fuck.
Ist das ein Fake. Warum kann ich das Bild nicht aufmachen Aliexpress. Aliexpress ich will das
Bild öffnen. Ok Aliexpress lässt mich das Bild nicht aufmachen. Dann mach ich ne VM
auf und schalte mal Adblock aus. Weil. Ich mein ist das ein Fake. Oder geht das wirklich.
What the fuck. Die meinen das wirklich Ernst.
Kannst du gerne eine Micro SD Card oder irgendwie so was rein machen. Ehe so rum wahrscheinlich.
Und PS2 Maus. Man kann das sogar. Ok das Ding muss ich mir bestellen. Ach du Scheiße.
Das sieht aus wie irgendwas was sie in der Ecke gefunden haben und was das seit 30
Jahren liegt. Klinken out. Was was sehe ich da. Vor allem gibt es da überhaupt Libraries
für dass man das verwenden kann. Perfekt. Nur perfekt. Nur perfekt. Das brauche ich
das Ding. Das muss ich mir bestellen. VGA 32. Das brauche ich das Teil. Jetzt ist vielleicht
auch woanders als bei Ali. Bei Banggood gibt es das noch. Jawoll. Aliexpress hat ja Steuerprobleme.
Ja das probieren wir im Stream aus. Ja. Nein ich agree. Ok das ist das ist Boomer programmiert
Mikro Controller. Ok gibt es das. Kriegen wir das auch irgendwo von einem Shop wo ich
das in nichts. Ach nee fuck. Kriegen wir das jetzt auch in irgendeinem Shop wo ich die
Sachen innerhalb von einer Woche mal habe. Wie sieht es bei Banggood aus. Banggood. Dennisxl.com.
Das klingt auch sehr vertrauenserweckend. Business Days. Banggood Germany Express. Und
Priority Line. Das ist auf jeden Fall auch gar nicht beim Zoll landet. Auch länger.
Ich finde das Ding irgendwie nice. Ich habe zwar keine Ahnung wie man das wirklich verwenden
soll aber die Idee finde ich cool. Was bei Aliexpress gibt es andere Versandoptionen.
Der hat jetzt aber kein Wlan. Doch der ESP23 hat immer Wlan. Ich hoffe aber. Ach so der
Raspberry Pi. Der hat kein Wlan. Was sagt. Deswegen verstehe ich den Sinn davon. Ich
bin mir nicht so sicher ob ich sowas von Aliexpress kaufen würde. Mini Tesla Spule. Bei Aliexpress
weiß ich da nie so genau. Ok wird nachher bestellt easy. Bestelle ich mir wirklich nachher.
Brauche ich nicht ausprobieren. Exzellent. Gut haben wir schon wieder was gelernt. Da
gibt es nichts. Ok was gucken wir uns als nächstes an. Modern Version. Snapchat. Äh
warum habe ich mein eigenes Video auf. Das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an. Guck mal das
Video war voll beliebt. Das hat nach 3 Tagen jetzt 41.000 Aufrufe. Keg. Keg. Postchamp
hier. Die letzten Videos sind eh übelst beliebt. Guckt euch das mal an. 41.000 nach ein paar
Tagen. 30.000. 50.000. 70.000. Ja gut da. 53.000. 100.000. Geht voll ab. Voll back im YouTube
Business Alter. Stonks. Ja läuft. Ich sollte mich vom FaZe Clan Sponsoren lassen. Einfach
so. Hat damit zwar gar nichts zu tun aber die bezahlen bestimmt gut. Ok meine eigenen
genug eigene Sachen promoted. Wir gucken eine Runde Kott. Irgendwie ist man es jetzt
danach. Wir gucken jetzt mal eine Runde. Fortschneid. Der macht immer gute Videos. World at War.
Ok. Ähm. Da hätte ich jetzt nicht drauf gewartet dass das playable ist. Das ist wahrscheinlich
playable wenn du 3 Stunden wartest auf eine Lobby auf der alten Xbox oder so. MP40 Juggernaut
Leute. MP40 Juggernaut. Paynes Champ. By the way ich hatte, Moment bevor wir das gucken
ich hatte noch eine richtig gute Idee für den Preis Champ. Wir machen Burger King Gutscheine
rein. Und zwar wisst ihr was ich auf GitHub gefunden habe. GitHub Burger King RP. Da
hat jemand die Burger King RP Endpoints für die Burger King App rausbekommen. Und wenn
man hier drauf geht kriegt man alle Gutschein Angebote von Burger King. Sofern man das lesen
kann. Oh man kann es nicht aufmachen. Jetzt muss ich mir das mal kurz angucken. Ja. Pay
Profet. Und die sind aktuell. Ich lasse mir das mal ausgeben. Ich muss mir das mal besser
printen lassen. Weil das kann ich so nicht lesen. Ähm. Kurl. So also. Aber wie wirken
ich jetzt minus R für Color. Ach. So genau. Weihnachtszeit ist Rösti Zeit. Oh. Gültig
bis ah das ist schon abgelaufen bis zum 19.01. Da müssen wir wahrscheinlich von oben anfangen.
Kann man nicht sagen Color. Color Output. Ah jetzt gehts. Also gültig bis. Unvermögen
nur in Teilen des Restaurants. Ok. Valid 4. Wo ist es denn? Eher bis zum 22.01. Äh.
Pequate ist schon abgelaufen. Ne Updated Exp. Am 8. am 8.2. läuft das aus. Barcodes. QR
Code. Äh. Kennt ihr den guten QR Code? QR Code Generator. Äh. Für Javascript oder
so. Demo. Weil dann könnte ich sogar einen Preischamp. Einen Preischamp einbauen, dass
dann ein QR Code für Burger King generiert. Update. Ja guck. QR Code of the day. Google
Storage API. Ok. Das kann man nicht öffnen. Wie. Ok da muss ich eingeloggt sein. Das funzt
hier nicht. Ne. Du musst den User Agent anpassen. Echt? Auf was? Das muss ich jetzt ausprobieren.
Ich muss Burger King Gutscheine. Brauche ich. Und dann? User Agent? Da sind Platzhalter.
Ok. Ne. Ne. Ne. User Agent. Das ist. Ne. Ne. Ne. Ne. Das war was anderes. Das sind
Platz. Ach guck mal. Das sind Platzhalter. Lul. Äh. Also schreiben wir mal da irgendwie
hin. 800 oder so. Ne. Ich darf da nicht drauf zugreifen. Na gut. Gibt es bestimmt andere
Möglichkeiten. Aber ich baue. Ich baue noch. Ich baue noch einen Burger King. Burger King
Gutschein Ding hier unten ein. Und da kommt dann in den Hintergrund als Animation rein.
Pippo Fett GIF. Ok jetzt kommen wir ins Video. Da sind wir stehen geblieben. Ah. Wo ist
es? Ja. Wie switchen die Desktops? Ähm. Control Windows Taste rechts ist Desktop Switchen.
Rechts und links mit den Pfeiltasten kannst du Desktop Switchen. Du kannst auch hier drüber
machen wenn man langsamer ist. Aber warum? Ne. Und hier kannst du auch neue Desktops
hinzufügen wenn du noch mehr brauchst. Ok jetzt haben wir. Wie viel gehen eigentlich?
Hab ich noch nie ausgebildet. Wie viel gehen maximal? Oh ist das schlecht gemacht. Alter
ist das schlecht gemacht diese App. Boah ist das kacke. Das läuft einfach aus dem Bildschirm
raus. Welcher Amateur bei Microsoft hat das wieder gebaut? Äh. Oh ist das schlecht gemacht.
Die Windows 10 Apps sind so unglaublich schlecht teilweise. Das ist der Wahnsinn. Scrollen.
Ne ich hab grad versucht. Du kannst hier nix machen. Vielleicht. Vielleicht. Vielleicht
mit dem Mausrad. Ne. Ach mit dem Mausrad gehts. Aber. Aber ziehen geht nicht oder was? Ach
hier unten. Alter das ist ja bedienbar. Oh Gott ist das schlecht äh. Ich hab gedacht
man kann hier einfach ziehen oder so. Aber ne das geht ja nicht. Überall Tablet. What
the fuck. Überall Tablet machen. Aber da wo es mal sinnvoll wäre die Tablet Sachen
zu verwenden da nicht. Wie viel gehen denn maximal Desktops? Wahrscheinlich 256 oder
irgendwie sowas. Guck mal jetzt hab ich hier. Massive Desktops. Der wird sehr schlecht
bei. Da kann man ja fast die Refresh Rate von seinem Monitor mit testen. Ok ich mach
mal wieder zu. Da kann ich die Dinger übrigens auch benennen. Ich mach mal wieder alles zu.
Ah yes. Exzellent. Exzellent. Ok jetzt guck mal aber das wird. Ey mp40 Juggernaut Leute
das war so OP der Kram. Kannst du nochmal erklären wofür virtuelle Desktops gut sind.
Ja im Prinzip für alles außer für virtuelle Desktops. Weil das einzige was nicht virtualisiert
ist ist ja der Desktop guck. Der Desktop hier. Also der Desktop ist ja wirklich überall
gleich. Ne. Also der Desktop hier und der Desktop da ist exakt der gleiche. Also das
einzige virtuelle ist. Also es ist alles virtuell außer der Desktop bei virtuellen Desktops
richtig hängen geblieben. Du kannst beispielsweise verschiedene Programme im Fullscreen haben
oder zwischendurch switchen. Das ist dafür wofür es ich verwende. Also du kannst hier
zum Beispiel Explorer im Fullscreen haben. Hier Browser im Fullscreen. Hier deine VM
im Fullscreen. Hier den Explorer im Fullscreen. Dafür verwende ichs. Ich hab beispielsweise
auf dem zweiten Desktop meine Linux VM. Mit auch mehreren Desktops. Das ist quasi
richtig Desktop Saption hier ineinander. Und dann kann ich halt zwischen VM und Windows
Desktop hin und her schalten. Das ist der hauptsächliche Anwendungszweck wofür ich
es hab. Weißt du ob mein Full-AMD PC ohne Grafikkarte ins BIOS booten müsste. Es gibt
doch heute kaum eine Kiste mehr ohne Onboard Grafikkarte. Bzw. ohne Grafikausgang von der
CPU. Der wird wahrscheinlich nicht mal ins BIOS booten. Der wird wahrscheinlich einfach
ganz normal booten. Ne Schnee liegt hier nicht. Hier Schneids. Hier Schneids. Aber es ist
zu warm. Es ist zu warm. Guck mal. Hanau. Wetter. Es ist ein bisschen zu warm. Echt die
Ryzens haben keine Onboard GPU. Ja dann nicht. Dann ist vorbei. Ohne GPU. Wenn du nix drin
hast. Oh. Was ist jetzt passiert? Das hab ich gar nicht gekriegt. MP40 Juggernautwerke.
Okay der ist host. Der ist definitiv host. So schnell wie er die gebashed hat. Ne ich
glaub ohne GPU wird das Ding nicht richtig angehen. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass
das ordentlich bootet. Theoretisch schon kann das auch booten ohne GPU aber das macht es
bestimmt nicht. Im Zweifelsfall ist das Windows ohne GPU statt. Das ist gar nicht. Ich hab
mal früher. Ich hab mal versucht in Windows ohne Grafikkarte laufen zu lassen. Kann ich
mich daran erinnern. Das ist ewig her. Das war in Pentium 2 400. Und das Ding hat mir
halt zu viel Strom verbraucht und ich weiß gar nicht mehr warum. Ich glaub das hat nicht
in die Kiste gepasst mit Grafikkarte. Also hab ich die Grafikkarte reingesteckt. Irgendeine
Rolle TNT 1 war das damals noch. Hab ich die Grafikkarte reingesteckt. Gebootet. Den Kram
gestartet. Den ich starten wollte. Und dann hab ich jetzt. Dann hab ich die Grafikkarte
einfach aus dem AGP Slot was damals. Ja AGP was glaub ich noch. Einfach die Grafikkarte
rausgezogen. Im laufenden Betrieb. Und ihr werdet lachen. Das lief danach noch. Ich konnte
mich danach per aderstop einloggen. Oh es ist PC. Mehr Spiele als Ghosts.
Mehr Spiele als BF3. Ne. Ne. Also selbst wenn du nur Official Battle Log nimmst ist das
mehr. Oh das hat ungefähr so viel. Bisschen mehr als Venice vielleicht. Dion-Deaf. Dionix-Deaf
ich hab keine Ahnung. Ich hab keine Ahnung wie er das gemacht hat. Genau wie die rumgeschrien
haben in CoD 5 immer. Habt ihr das gehört? Das ist äh Trainiart oder wie das? Ne. Ich
hab selbst. Ach keine Ahnung wie die Map heißt. Habt ihr das gesehen wie die Map heißt?
Bäm. Weggesprät. Moment. Man hat in CoD 4 genubtubt mit der Bazooka. Das war mir jetzt
neu. Weggesprät. Es ist bestimmt voller Hexor. Konnte man. Konnte man. Gab es zu CoD 5 noch
Custom Server? Also was was man selber hosten konnte und im Zweifelsfall da auch äh
irgendwelche Sachen mit automatischen Buns und so. Schreckt. Guck mal sogar Teams Auto
mit. Ich muss meine Sensitivität ein bisschen öffnen. Okay. Nimm die. Weggesprät.
Spidey. Spidey. Was auch immer. Recom Plane. Dreizehn versus dreizehn auf der Konsole
war es was? Acht versus acht? Auch ich hab das nicht so lange gespielt, dass ich
eigentlich wieder aufstehen musste. Äh dieser Server, du bekommst etwa plus fünfhundert
pro Kille, was viel ist. Also es ist irgendwie wie XXXP. Aber äh das Suckigste ist, dass
ich alle Attachments für die Waffe wieder aufstehen muss. Und es gibt keinen schnellen
Weg. Aber so Leute gibt's immer noch. Ich frag mich halt ganz im Ernst, warum spielt
einer ein fünftausend Jahre altes CoD und dann setzt er sich nur mit einer LMG hinter
einer Barriere und peekt rüber. Also dafür würde ich mir das Game Card dann installieren.
Historiker. Ja, genau, der will Realismus, Realismus Modus spielen.
Das Ding war cool. Das war die japanische Submachine Gun. Oh, der wollte den messern.
Oh, die war geil, die war geil. Wobei man halt sagen muss, MP40 Juggernaut war beste.
Das Game hatte auch viele coole Waffen. Also du konntest auch das meiste irgendwie spielen.
Außer die, also was nicht gut war, was nicht gut war, waren die Semi Auto Rifles. Das hat
viel zu lang gedauert. Bis du da was gekillt hast, zumindest auf der Konsole. Das STJ war
noch cool. Ich kann mich da gar nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern.
Doch, das war das Game mit Panzern, ja. Aber das hat gesackt. Also Panzer in dem Spiel
war wirklich Müll. Und die Panzermaps waren auch viel zu groß. Zumindest auf der Konsole.
Vielleicht spielt es sich auf dem PC besser mit 13 vs. 13. Die Panzermaps ging damals
auch nie bis zum Ende der, also ging immer bis zum Time Limit, nicht bis zum Score Limit.
Da liegt er. Last Stand, stimmt. Ich wollte gerade sagen, hat er seine Hunde am Start
nicht ausgelöst. Oh, Grenade. Da hat er mich gesehen. Gebashed wird. War das so? Das war
damals nicht so, oder? Dass die Killstreaks wieder von vorne angefangen haben. Normalerweise
war vorbei. Deswegen haben ja auch die ganzen High Killstreak Leute, also die Killstreak
Leute sich immer gekillt, nachdem sie den Killstreak erreicht haben. Das haben sie wahrscheinlich
gemoddert, was ja auch eine gute Idee ist. Ok, daran erkennt man schon das Game. Heute
würde zumindest diese Säule nicht mehr ganz so eckig aussehen. Heute würden sie irgendwas
machen, dass die Säule irgendwie mal hier ein paar Beschädigungen rein oder so. Heute
wäre nicht so eine Säule, einfach nur noch eine Säule. Komplett rechteckig, könnte
aus Quake 2 sein. Die Maps sind, die Maps in Code 5 hier, wenn man sie sieht, man erkennt
ja schon, dass das alles, das ist schon alles enorm eckig und ohne Details. Was? Der Witz
habe ich nicht verstanden. Bestimmt Kokona-Joke. Oder ich bin zu Boomer für, was ein paar
Spielwitzen der Fall ist. Weggesprayt. Ach stimmt, das war das Game, wo man den Gegner
noch irgendwie Beine absprengen konnte. Football-Joke, ok. Ok. Alles klar, Football-Joke. Da weißt
du Bescheid. Alter, warum lassen sie sich so weggesprayt von ihm?
Der bestie aber schon ganz schön weg. Ich überlege gerade, habe ich das Game überhaupt
auf dem PC? Ich müsste das Game auf dem PC haben. Vielleicht gucke ich da heute Abend
auch mal rein. Ich schreibe mir das mal kurz auf, dass ich das nicht vergesse nachher.
Mal ausprobieren. Ich glaube, ich habe es auf dem PC. Es könnte aber auch sein, dass
ich davor war, mir das zu kaufen, vor Jahren und es da nie gekauft habe. Ich kaufe mir
so auf jeden Fall nicht, wie viel das auf Steam kostet. Oh ne, die deutsche Version?
20 Euro? Das ist aber noch die deutsche Version, ohne, oh ne, oh ne, oh ne, oh ne, oh ne, oh
ne. Gibt es das auf GOG oder so? Kann man das ohne Steam spielen auf dem PC? Oh ne, das
spiele ich nicht. Definitiv spiele ich nicht. Das ist die deutsche Version. Das ist ohne
Punkte, da siehst du nicht, wer du eingekillt hast. Kann dir die Uncut Version aus der Schweiz,
geht das? Sind Gifts dann die original Version? Okay, könnte sein, ja. CLI Jumper, das ist
Absicht. Deswegen steht er da auch in Arbeit dahinter, weil der Graph noch nicht funktioniert.
Ich meine, allein schon das in dem Graph, was unter UVP ist, ist ja absolut unvorstellbar
aktuell. Naja, das ist ja Standard. Also gerade auf dem PC, weil alle Games Chat haben
und die Leute Tastatur. Ich meine, in Venice ist auch jede Runde Hacker-Anschuldigungen
und sowas am Start gegen irgendwelche Leute. Wobei es halt echt so ist. Mittlerweile
hat sich das rumgesprochen, dass es am Start ist. Das sind auch mittlerweile viele. Da vergeht
kaum noch eine Runde, wo nicht was Verdächtiges ist. Deswegen habe ich die letzten Partei
auch nicht richtig gespielt. Also, da müssen die Server-Admins echt mal ein bisschen gucken.
Wobei ich ja das Gefühl habe, dass manche Server-Admins selbst da nicht ganz sauber
sind. Also wer 1911 hat und cheatet, da hat er entweder schlechte Cheats oder er ist so
unterschiedlich unter ihr, die schlecht, dass es es auch nicht mehr rausreißt. Wie würde
denn Anti-Cheat bei Venice gehen? Ganz einfach, du brauchst einen Server, wo Admins drauf
sind, die gucken, was abgeht und die Leute kicken.
Denkst du, Grafiker und CPU sinken immer wieder auf normale Preise im Sommer irgendwann vielleicht?
Bäm, oh voll die Eier gesprayt. Danach gucken wir mal, ob es neue Battlefield-Topplays
gibt. Hat jemand gesehen, was er für Perks spielt? Hat er Stopping-Power oder Juggernaut
am Start? Sag mal, was ist mit den Gegnern wieder los? Guckt euch mal den Dude an. Pass
mal auf, der Typ. Warum killt der oder ist das ein Team-Mate von ihm? Das ist ein Gegner,
der will den Bayonetten, kann das sein? Der will Melee Only machen. Alter Gegner, was
ist mit euch los? NA-Gegner. Ich fand auch geil, ich fand auch den John Wack ist am Start,
ich fand auch den Ansager geil, der versucht hat dann, der halt eindeutig nicht deutsch
war, aber versucht hat, so mit deutschem Akzent dann herumzustreien. Du hast doch in
World 5 den Typ Force of the Motherland. Hast du doch am Start, den Typ Force of the Motherland.
Kann ich mir dran erinnern. Okay, die Waffe, das war die Waffe, die ich
war die einzig brauchbare, die einzig brauchbare Semi-Auto-Waffe. Okay, das ist Schneiber-Action,
hier die da, das war M1-Kabine oder so war das glaube ich, das war die einzig brauchbare
Semi-Auto-Waffe, schwer zu sagen. Oh jetzt wird hier sniped. Okay Leute, meint ihr das
ist legit, wer kann so schnell, meint ihr der Tap legit? Guckt mal, guckt mal. Der Typ
sitzt halt einfach da, der sitzt halt einfach da und hat eine Wirklichkeit so, hier den
da, den da macht der, der spielt einfach, der sitzt schon über der Maus und sobald
er geht, so geht das. Warte mal, es gab doch so ein Test, wie schnell man klicken kann.
Muss ich mal ausprobieren, wie schnell ich das überhaupt maximal hinbekommen würde.
Feuern auf Mausrad, ich glaube Feuern auf Mausrad kann man nicht metten, aber man könnte garantiert
das in dem Maustreiber irgendwie machen. Okay, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, ich weiß
nicht ob das das ist, aber checken wir mal. Mal gucken, mal gucken, wie schnell. Okay,
also, also. Okay Leute. Postchamp. Ups. Hallo? Okay. Auf geht's, auf geht's. Wie setze ich
mich denn da jetzt am besten hin? Wie setze ich mich da am besten hin? Ich muss die Maus
irgendwie so hinlegen, dass ich da drauf komm, so. Okay. Oh, nice, easy, easy win. Es geht
noch schneller, Leute. Es geht noch schneller. Ich bin ein Cheater, guck mal. Restart. Okay,
noch mal. Es geht noch, geht noch schneller. Da muss man sich ein bisschen dran gewöhnen.
Oh, Alter. Okay, das ist zu anstrengend. Nice, easy, easy, easy cheater, easy cheater.
Bei der Windows 10 Installation geübt. Easy cheater. Oh, boy, there's so many back here.
Jetzt noch mal mit normaler. Okay, okay, okay, Moment. Ich mach mal ohne beidhändig, ich
mach mal ohne beidhändig. Fuck, ich hab vergessen. Click, click, speedtest oder wie war das? Click,
speedtest. Okay, jetzt mal, wie schnell ich realistisch, sagen wir mal, in einem Shooter
tappen könnte. Das geht natürlich bei weitem nicht so schnell. Na ja, ich bin ein Octopost.
Also nur mit dem Finger. Ich meine, ich kann natürlich einfach, ich kann natürlich auch
so cheaten, aber das ist nicht, also wenn ich wirklich, wenn ich die Maus so halte,
wie ich sie im Spiel halte, dann kann ich höchstens, höchstens so klicken in der
Geschwindigkeit. Schneller geht nicht. Also sprich, das Tappfire, was du bei dem Typ
gesehen hast, glaube ich nicht, dass man es hinkriegt. Oh, God. Okay, I see you. I should
pick up that other MP40 as well. Nice. Someone else picked it up. Ah, jetzt hat er auch das
Ding am Start. Bam, bub, bam, bub, bam. Oh, I saw him. He saw me too. Jetzt wird, jetzt
wird er gleich weggetriggert. Oh, someone else just called their artillery and great timing.
The artillery was einfach nur mega random. Spray, spray, spray, spray. Excellent. Ja,
so guck dir, in der Geschwindigkeit kann man tappen. Man kann übrigens ja auch, man muss
ja dabei noch zielen. Also, das ist gar nicht mal so easy da so extrem schnell zu tippen.
Oh, Eier. Die Kommandakrieger Wauzis. Pains Jam. Ja, Battlefield Video habe ich eben auch
gerade geguckt. 40k plus, ne? Richtig nice. Ein Vorteil hatten, eins muss man echt sagen,
also ein Vorteil, was diese alten Call of Duty Dinger haben, du hast alles gut erkannt.
Ja, da konnte nicht irgendwie mal ein Gegner hier neben liegen und der lag mitten im Müll
und du hast ihn nicht gesehen und du konntest in der Regel auch ganz gut Freund von Feinden
unterscheiden. Also, es war viel weniger klatter so am Start. Und die Straßenschilder in Call
of, in World of War war auch immer geil, die haben überhaupt kein normales Deutsch. Was
ist das für eine Straße? Moment. Okay, tatsächlich, die gibt's. Aber manche Sachen waren halt
texturmäßig total fail, gerade wenn Deutsch drauf stand. Was stand auf Nuke immer? Vorsicht,
Vorsicht, Kran, Vorsicht vor den Kran oder irgendwie sowas? Gefahr durch Kran, Gefahr
durch Kran, stand da, genau. Gefahr, Gefahr durch Kran, stand da immer. Nuke. Gefahr durch
Kran, ja. Bitt, please. Messer, MSC legit. Ja, zieh bloß das Problem, was ich bei Venice
aktuell hab, ist, dass es im Prinzip, es gibt den Pink Server, da sind teilweise sehr
merkwürdige Leute drauf in den letzten Tagen, und der Rush Server, wo letztens nice Cheater
Stels am Start war, deswegen konnte ich nicht, konnte ich nicht, hab ich jetzt die letzten
paar Teilnehmer gespielt. Okay, komm, es wird Zeit, also wenn er schon mp40 spielt,
können wir allerdings auch Juggernaut rein machen, dass wir die OP Kombi haben. Der Typ
sitzt halt da und guckt geradeaus. Ich frag mich immer, warum die Leute manchmal so Spiele
installieren, um sich dann irgendwo hinzusetzen und geradeaus zu gucken. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh. Oh.
Wo, weiß der, dass da einer? Okay, ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, in World of War musste
man nach dem Spawn direkt die Nate raushauen, weil, dass man sie auf jeden Fall benutzt
hat, zumindest hab ich mir das damals immer eingeredet. Ich bin immer gespawrt und hab
gleich die Granate rausgehauen, und damit hat man öfters mal was gekillt, als man gedacht
hat, oh weg, sniper. Oh my god, what the? Sniper man. Jetzt werden sie weg, mp40. Bam,
jawoll. Jawoll. Oh, oh, oh, Nate, Nate. Wow, dass er nicht davon getroffen wurde. Das
war meine Lieblingswaffe in dem Spiel. Thompson Extended Mags, das hab ich am liebsten gespielt.
Der mp40 Juggernaut war sogar mir zur OP. Thompson Extended Mag, beste. Der Typ sitzt
immer noch da und guckt geradeaus. Seht ihr mal, wie spaß die Spiele sein können, ohne
Skillbase Matchmaking. Gut, in dem Fall hat es viel zu wenig Spieler für Skillbase Matchmaking.
Und man würde vorausgehen, die Spieler, die da sind, sind auch noch ganz gut, aber anscheinend
nicht. Ich sag's euch, ich sag's euch, wie es ist. Wir freuen uns vielleicht, also mal
angenommen Battlefield 6 sieht gut aus, dann freuen wir uns alle auf Battlefield 6 und
es kommt raus, es gibt keinen Serverbrowser mehr und Skillbase Matchmaking. Dann ist Riven
RIP, nee, da wird's nicht gekauft. 7 Monate Eliminator, danke schön für den Sub. Also
ohne Scheiß mit Skillbase Match, ich kauf mit dem Scheiß nicht. Ich hab keine Probleme,
wenn's den Rank-Modus gibt. Dann kann man wenigstens mit seinem Rank ein bisschen Schwanzvergleich
machen. Aber nicht einfach in Public Matchmaking, das seh ich nicht ein. What the fuck, was macht
das grad? Haben die alle aneinander vorbei gemessert? Der wollt ihn mehlen, der wollt
ihn mehlen, der hat nicht getroffen, der hat nicht getroffen. Warum hat das Knife nicht
getroffen gerade? Boah, was ist das? Oh, das ist die Apple Frau, die erzählt mir, dass
kein Akku mehr, dass kein Akku mehr in der Packung ist. Übrigens achtet mal drauf, wie
geil Apple das... Habt ihr das mitgekriegt, wie Apple das begründet hat? Das ist der
Ausschnitt hier, jetzt geh ich mal von aus. Wie Apple das begründet hat, warum kein Ladegerät
mehr im iPhone drin ist. Apple hat gesagt, so nach dem Motto, ja, eigentlich hat es eh
noch nie jemand gebraucht und wir schützen die Umwelt und wir sparen seltene Ressourcen,
dadurch, dass wir kein Ladegerät mehr beilegen. Aber, aber, ein iPhone, da sieht man mal,
man macht einfach was raus, rein ganz klar, um noch mehr Geld zu machen und dann erzählt
man den Leuten irgendeinen Scheiß, warum man das macht, was mit der Realität überhaupt
nichts zu tun hat. Kann ich lauter machen, das ist so leise. Precious Materials, ja, das
ist gerade, ist gerade bei einer iPhone Herstellung für den, für das Ladegerät, ist nochmal
wirklich ganz, ganz schlimm, ja. Was ist das? Was geht mit denen ab, ey? Es schreckt die
Leute nicht so. Ja gut, Samsung hat ja gesagt, sie, also, okay, ich weiß wo das Video hin
will. Samsung hat ja gesagt, guck mal, hier bei uns ist der Akku noch dabei und jetzt
vor ein paar Tagen hat Samsung gesagt, nee, ist doch kein Akku mehr dabei. Also ganz ehrlich,
ich hab noch nie rumgeheult, weil ein Ladegerät dabei ist. Man kann ja eigentlich nicht genug
Ladegeräte haben. Alter, die Musik. Fällt euch mal auf, wie ähnlich der Crap mittlerweile
aussieht. Samsung hat sich ja jetzt auch davon verabschiedet, einfach ganz gute, günstige
Android-Smartphones zu machen, die machen quasi ein auf Apple 2.0. Genau, genau, danke Samsung,
dass ihr uns rettet. Bin ich froh, dass es Samsung und Apple auf der Welt gibt, ich wüsste
nicht. Okay, Watercooled Raspberry Pi 4 Cluster. Scheint mir äußerst sinnlos zu sein, aber
ist bestimmt nice. Weiter mal, wisst ihr, wie ich das mit dem Ladegerät mache? Ich
hab schon seit ein paar Jahren jetzt einfach ein Kabel am Start mit Micro-USB, USB-C und
Thunderbolt Anschluss. Nee, Lightning. Und dann kann ich einfach alles dranladen, was
ich will. So, fertig. Sonst drehst du ja durch mit der Zeit. So leise. Also, ich will jetzt
ja nichts dagegen sagen. Es ist sicherlich ein echt cooles Projekt, aber sinnvoll ist
es nicht. Ich glaube, da ist Sinn für uns einig und der Ersteller auch. Aber cool ist
es. Es geht halt. Ja, das stimmt, man braucht auch gar keinen Fan, man macht einfach ein
Gehäuse, was aus Alu ist und das gut über das ganze Gehäuse ableitet. Das geht. Wir
haben so letztens sogar selbst so ein Ding zusammengebaut. Ich, das ist auch sowas,
was ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden hab, wo die Daseinsberechtigung vom Raspberry Pi
Cluster ist. Es ist cool, man kann damit Sachen üben. Also, wenn man beispielsweise mal daheim
einen Kubernetes Cluster administrieren will zum Üben, ist ein Raspberry Pi Cluster sicherlich
cool. Allerdings muss man sich halt nicht einreden, dass sich das irgendwie lohnen
würde von der Rechenleistung her. Ich mein, wenn du wirklich Rechenleistung brauchst,
dann nimmst du einfach irgendeinen x-beliebigen 8-Core-Desktop-CPU, irgendeinen Low-End-Risen
oder was auch immer und da bist du meilenweit vor irgendeinem Raspberry Pi Cluster. Ich
mein, es verbraucht vielleicht ein bisschen mehr, aber so supersparsam ist ein Raspberry
Pi Cluster auch nicht. Also ein Raspberry Pi 4, volle Pulle unter Last, der kann auch
mal 12, 13 Watt verbrauchen oder sagen wir mal 15. Da kannst du auch in so einem Cluster
auch einen ganz ordentlichen 8-Core-Risen laufen lassen. Zwar okay nicht unter Volllast, aber
die Daseinsberechtigung ist, finde ich, nicht so ganz da. Wäre die nämlich da, dann würden
die ganzen Krypto-Miner sich ihr Keller mit Raspberry Pi vollstellen, wenn es das bessere
Preis-Leistung bieten würde. Strom zu Stromkosten zu Mining. Es gibt Water-Cooling-Kits für
Raspberry Pi, ernsthaft? Tatsächlich. Okay. Wobei, das ist einfach ein ganz normaler Kühlblock,
oder? Das hat mit dem Raspberry Pi nichts zu tun. Oh, jetzt wird's, JETZT WIRT'S ABER
ADVANCED. Der Typ hat, der Typ schneidet sich, der hat so, wie heißen diese Dinger, so eine
CNC, oder was weiß ich, mit Laser anstatt Bohrer, und er schneidet sich aus Plastik jetzt
die Halterung für. JETZT IST ABER ADVANCED. Ich meine, er hätte es auch 3D-Drucken können,
allerdings muss man halt sagen, 3D-Drucken dauert wahrscheinlich länger. Und es sieht
nicht so sauber aus dann. Ähm, dazu kommt, also Ding ist cool, was kosten sowas? Was kosten
sowas? AliExpress. Wie ist das? Ich mein, ich brauch's nicht, ich brauch mal 3D, 3D,
nicht Laster, Alter. Laser-Cutter. Ich brauch schon, ich brauch mein Kram ja schon kaum.
Ah, easy, nice. Gibt's das auch billiger? Ah, hier. Äh, Loki fragt, das ist eine äußerst
interessante Frage, da kann ich mich mal ein bisschen zu auslassen, weil das eigentlich
der Hauptgrund ist, warum Leute VPN verwenden. Kann ich mir einen VPN, kann ich mit einem
VPN sicher vom Torrensorfer tun oder bringt das nichts? Das kommt drauf an, traust du
deinem VPN-Anbieter, dass er keine Daten rausrückt, auch wenn die Polizei vor der Tür steht?
Das ist das erste, was du dich fragen musst. Ähm, und das nächste ist, du musst das ordentlich
benutzen. Also sprich, du musst dann auch gucken, dass du nicht Dinger darüber sendest,
die dich identifizierbar machen. In dem Torrenzeug. Was dann im Zweifelsfall in den Logs vom Torrensorfer
drinsteht, weil es bringt ja nichts, um es jetzt mal ganz easy zu sagen, wenn irgendwo
inline deine Adresse, es ist nicht so, ja, aber ich sag's mal, es gibt ja auch andere
Sachen, die einen identifizieren können. Mal genommen, man hat irgendwelche Überreste,
irgendwelche Sachen, die in den Paketen drinstehen, die gelockt werden auf dem Server, die das
identifizierbar machen, dann ist auch egal, ob man dadurch einen VPN gegangen ist oder
nicht. Oder, wenn man gleichermaßen nebenbei Dinger macht, äh, über das VPN, zum Beispiel
E-Mails abruft, wenn du parallel über das VPN E-Mails abrufst und man deine E-Mail-Adresse
im Klartext zieht, ist auch kacke. Du musst auch aufpassen, dass keine Torrent-Packages
geleakt werden, das kann durchaus mal sein, wenn die VPN-Software sagt, dass, ähm, Torrent-Packages
dann quasi nicht durchs VPN gehen, sondern eventuell mal über dein normalen Internet
ausgehen. Also, man muss auf einiges achten, weil man wirklich anonym sein will. Und, ähm,
tja, sollte man sich halt vielleicht überlegen, ob man den Kram, ob es sich wirklich lohnt,
ja. Gerade Torrent ist halt anfällig für, dass man erwischt wird. Was ist eigentlich
aus guten alten Newsnet-Groups geworden? Für irgendwelches Zeug, wo man sich nicht kaufen
will. Gibt's da einen Scheiß noch? Früher war Newsnet voll angesagt. Also, wenn ich,
Leute, ich sag euch mal, was ich machen würde. Wenn ich, wenn ich wirklich anonym irgendwas
machen möchte, das, das Mindeste, was ich machen würde, ist eine Linux-VM, Kali, irgendwas,
Tor Browser und, ähm, dann geh ich in ein öffentliches WLAN und mach das da drüber.
Also, die Kombination erscheint mir doch immer noch relativ sicher, ja. Also, irgendeine
Linux-VM mit Tor Browser und dann über ein öffentliches WLAN. So, das bringt natürlich
für Torrent-Downloads nichts. Oder Tails, genau, Tails ist ja da auch angesagt. Also,
im Prinzip irgendeine Linux mit Tor Browser, VM drauf, oder man kann es ja auch direkt
drauf installieren, ist egal, und ins öffentliche WLAN. Das ist dann schon mal, da kann man
sich da halbwegs sicher sein, dass da einem keiner auf die Schliche kommt. Also, wenn
ich wirklich anonym machen würde, würde ich wahrscheinlich sowas so machen. Ähm, man
kann auch beim Nachbar ins WLAN, wenn das offen ist, oder wie auch immer, würde ich
aber nicht machen, weil das ist ja im Prinzip neben euch, das findet man dann auch relativ
schnell. Man muss sich halt immer fragen, was will man da eigentlich machen? Also, braucht
man das überhaupt? Ich hab mir die letzten Jahre nichts illegal mehr runtergeladen, weil
ich mir alles mittlerweile kaufe, wenn es es zu kaufen gibt. Die einzigen Sachen, die
ich mir, okay, stimmt nicht, das stimmt nicht, die einzigen Sachen, die ich mir manchmal
angucke sind halt Dinge, die es vielleicht auf Amazon nicht mit Originalton gibt oder
irgendwas. Also irgendwas, was ich eigentlich kaufen will, aber nicht kaufen kann. Dann eventuell
vielleicht, ja. Ja, gut, Matt, irgendein Tod musst du sterben, ja. Und insofern, kannst
du das immer noch weiter ausbauen, dann machst du dir irgendeinen Filter auf dein Bildschirm,
dass keiner was sehen kann, dann setzt du dich eben. Es gibt zig Varianten, du kannst ja auch
versuchen, ob du nicht irgendwie an eine Prepaid, was auch immer, SIM-Karte kommst und das
da, was auch immer. Da gibt es ja zig Varianten, aber man muss sich erstmal fragen, ob man
das überhaupt braucht. Nein, das kontrolliert keiner. Es ging aber nur darum, ob du erwischt
werden kannst und das ist halt der Fall. Wenn du privat Streams guckst, also wenn ihr da
jetzt irgendwie auf, ich sag jetzt keine Seite, aber wenn ihr da auf irgendeine Film-Streaming-Seite
geht, weil ihr euch irgendwie die neuesten japanischen Anime-Stell-Sachen angucken wollt,
das mag zwar nicht legal sein, aber ich hab mir, als die letzte Dragon Ball Staffel gelaufen
ist, hab ich mir die auch über die Streaming-Seite angeguckt, weil es das nicht in Deutschland
gab. Okay, who cares, ja. Das juckt keinen, das juckt keinen wirklich und es ist auch
fraglich, wie illegal das ist. Es ist glaube ich nur illegal, wie gesagt, ich hab da keine
Ahnung von, ich kann euch auch keine verlässlichen Ratschläge geben, aber ich glaube, es ist
auch hauptsächlich nur illegal, wenn du erkennen kannst, dass das illegal ist. Also sprich,
wenn die Seite schon übel scammy aussieht, wenn das einfach nur eine normale Seite ist,
dann kannst du immer noch sagen, was, das ist illegal, wusste ich gar nicht. Und im Zweifelsfall
interessiert dir das auch nicht, wenn du das einfach anguckst. Also wie gesagt, ich würd
mir den Kram alles kaufen und ich kauf mir den Kram auch alles halt nur Sachen, die ich
nicht kaufen kann und mir trotzdem angucken will, dann bleibt mir nix anderes übrig. Das
ist auch immer weniger, solange man sich im Zweifelsfall auch einen ausländischen Netflix-Account
machen kann, was ja nicht illegal ist. Ja gut, bei Torrent musst du halt aufpassen, das Problem
an Torrent ist, das Problem an Torrent ist ja, dass du Sachen sharesst, dass du nicht
nur downloadest. Man kann zwar modifizierte Torrent-Client verwenden, die nix uploaden,
aber ich glaube, das macht dann auch Probleme, irgendwann kickt dich der Tracker oder was
auch, keine Ahnung. Torrent ist die unsicherste Variante, was du machen kannst. Also Torrent
suckt halt mal richtig, wenn es darum geht. Also wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wie angesagt
Usenet auch ist, das war früher voll angesagt, um Sachen zu Zeiten, wo man beispielsweise
Musik nicht kaufen konnte, weil die noch gesagt haben, bitte kauft alle CDs, da hat man auch
manchmal im Usenet oder früher davor noch Napster, was da alles gab, oder Torrent ist
halt doof, weil bei Torrent lädst du hoch, das heißt, du brauchst auch schon mal nicht,
du brauchst da irgendwie was halbwegs mit ein bisschen Bandbreite, dass das gescheit
funktioniert und Torrent macht auch viele Verbindungen auf, also Torrent ist da nicht
das Beste. Das Beste ist, du findest irgendwie einen Download-Link und das machst du über
einen VPN oder so, dann ist die Chance, dass das irgendjemand merkt, doch relativ gering.
Manchmal und du findest irgendwie einen Mega- oder was auch immer Download-Link, das lädst
du über einen VPN, dann ist es eigentlich sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass das dir mal
nicht irgendwie zum Verhängnis wird.
Warum macht er mit Wärmerleitpaste nochmal was unten dran? Wo ist der Sinn davon? Warum
kann er das nicht direkt rot? Achso, wahrscheinlich weil der Block zu groß ist für den Raspberry
Pi. Oder dass er es besser abkriegt? Ich meine, der hat gerade Wärmerleitpaste genommen
auf den Metall und dann wieder Wärmerleitpaste, warum macht er nicht den Block direkt drauf?
Aber wie gesagt, ich glaube ja, weil es nicht passt. Ist auch geil, das ist der Cooling-Block
und die CPU ist da unten so irgendwie 1cm drauf. Ich meine, es hat was, es ist schon
cool. Da hat er aber Glück, guck mal. Ja, das hat er, das hat er, das hat er, das hat
er. Guck mal, der Kamerakonnektor ist gerade klein genug. Ah, TP-Link. Habt ihr schon
den UniFi-Klon von TP-Link gesehen? Ich kann nur immer wieder sagen, wer einen Switch
braucht und damit auch ein bisschen was machen will, einfach nicht, also wenn ihr nicht einfach
ein passives Netzwerkgerät haben wollt, sondern daran beispielsweise VLAN-Settings machen
könnt oder auch ein paar Sachen, dann würde ich immer zu den MikroTik-Switchen kaufen,
vor allem wenn es ein bisschen Performance haben soll und auch ein 10G-Uplink. Also die
MikroTik-Switche sind preisleistungsmäßig wirklich super. Die sollten mich sponsoren.
Was ist das? Wow, das ist ja eine coole Sache. Da gibt es einfach 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 Anschlüsse.
Eigentlich eine coole Geschichte. Ja, die Fritzbox hat zu wenig Ports. Ich frage mich eh warum
die nicht mal eine Fritzbox machen mit 8 Ports. Wo ist das Problem? Wer kommt mit, was hat
die Fritzbox 5 und davon ein Externus? Das reicht doch hin und vorne nicht. Das ist ein
Ding, das frage ich mich seit Jahren schon, Flintstone 1490. Warum die nicht eine Fritz-Switch
rausbringen? Die müssen ja selbst keinen Switch bauen. Die Fritzbox selbst, weiß ich
auch nicht, wie viel da wirklich von denen selbst ist. Die können das einfach reprinten,
aber der Scheiß verkauft sich. Was meint ihr, wie viele Noobs das gibt, die dann wieder
erzählen, am besten funktioniert eine Fritzbox mit einem Fritzbox-Switch. Das sind die Leute,
die früher auch gesagt haben, Nvidia-Mainboard mit Nvidia-Grafikkarte und Intel-CPU ist besser
als AMD mit AMD-Grafikkarte oder AMD mit Nvidia-Grafikkarte. Das geht ja überhaupt nicht. Deswegen frage
ich mich, warum die nicht einen Fritzbox-Switch rausbringen. Dann müssten die Fritzbox doch
WLANs können. Nö, nicht zwangsläufig. Es wäre cool, wenn sie das mal hinkriegen würden,
weil WLAN-Support wäre echt noch was Praktisches an der Fritzbox. Aber du brauchst ja keinen
WLAN-Support, dass du einen Switch machen kannst. Oder DHCP oder PXE kann. Kann eine Fritzbox
kein DHCP? Achso, der PXE kann. Kannst du bei der Fritzbox kein Next-Server eintragen
beim DHCP? Ja gut, kann ich mir schon vorstellen. Doch, der normale Consumer würde auch einen
Fritzbox-Switch kaufen, weil der normale Consumer auch zu viele Geräte hat. Guck mal, du hast
vier Ports an der Fritzbox. Die Leute schließen ihre Playstation, ihre Xbox an, ihren PC
an, ihren Drucker an und dann ist voll. Oder sie sagen halt, wir machen den Scheiß ins
W dann wundern sich warum sie rumlecken. Ah, also du kommst auch als normaler Consumer
easy an vier-Port-Grenze. Fritzbox ist auch gut. Es gibt eigentlich nix dagegen. Die Fritzbox
ist ein super Multifunktionsgerät. Die Fritzbox ist halt kein wirklich richtig guter Router
oder ein guter Switch. Aber die Fritzbox ist ein gutes Multifunktionsgerät. Und ich bin
auch froh, dass die Fritzbox halbwegs ordentlich VoIP kann, weil VoIP ist nix, was du selbst
machen willst. Und deswegen, die sollten einen Fritzbox-Switch machen. Der sieht dann genauso
aus, hat dann irgendwie acht Ports, 16 Ports, vielleicht sogar bis 24, ganz fetter dann,
und sieht auch so aus wie eine Fritzbox. Und da gibt es genug Leute, die sagen, ich habe
mir eine Fritzbox und einen offiziellen Fritzbox-Switch und seitdem ist mein Internet viel schneller.
Und die behaupten das dann und die schwören dann da drauf. Ich hatte das vorher. Vorher
hatte ich nur die Fritzbox und mein Netz und mein PC direkt dran. Seit ich den Fritzbox-Switch
habe, ist mein Internet viel schneller und die schwören dann da richtig drauf. Jujim,
18 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub. Huge Sub-Script. Seitdem druckt mein Drucker auch
viel schneller. Du kannst keine Donation machen, du kannst höchstens haben. Donation habe
ich rausgenommen, weil tippistream irgendwie den Link verkackt hat und seitdem habe ich
keine Donation zu bereiten. Ich weiß, es ist eigentlich basic. Normalerweise machst du
noch bevor du auch nur einen Subscriber oder einen Follower hast, schon einen Donation-Link
rein. Aber ich bin ja eh nicht ganz normal, was das angeht. Ich habe ja auch von 28 Emote-Slots
nur 8 Emotes drin. Oder, genau, spend lieber ans Tierheim. Ist besser als bei mir zu spenden.
Aber ansonsten kannst du mir auch einen Sub dalassen. Prime-Sub kostet ja nichts, wenn
du Amazon Prime hast. Da freue ich mich drüber. Ansonsten, wenn du spenden willst, spende
an irgendwas lokal nicht an mich. Musenik, 18 Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub. Exquisite
Subscription. Du kannst auch ein Tier 3 Sub machen, da kriege ich sogar 70% von ab.
Wieviel Normalos kennst du, die mehr Geräte anschließen wie Alan? Ich kenne kaum Leute,
deswegen ist, also ich kenne kaum normale Leute, also ich kenne eh kaum Leute, mit denen
ich enger in Kontakt bin, auf die ich Bock habe und davon dann auch noch normale Leute,
davon gibt es nicht mehr so viel. Also kann ich dir, kann ich die Frage nicht beantworten.
Kannst du einen Tierheim-Link einfügen, wo man spenden kann? Äh, ja, da müsste ich
mir erstmal über raussuchen, welches. Ich habe, ich habe an Weihnachten ein bisschen
was gespendet als Tierheim, wo ich Chico her habe, weil die haben auf ihrer Homepage auch
wieder geschrieben, dass sie viel zu wenig haben für, für alles, ja. Ob du nochmal ein
Video über Musik machst beim letzten Mal, habe ich echt keine Ahnung. Oh, das ist zu
Nische auf YouTube, das juck, keinem. Und ich kann auch nicht mal im Stream irgendwelche
Musik, das sagt richtig, sonst hätte ich jetzt mal was cooles gezeigt, weil ich mir
in letzter Zeit, ne, kann ich nicht mehr machen, das ist Musik und Twitch. Ja, Spicke, da hast
du recht, vor allem Donation. Na, wenn du dir überlegst, du, ich bin, was weiß ich,
stellt euch vor, ich wäre irgendwie Boopcam-Streamerin mit 5000 Zuschauern, ich bekomme
Donations, weil ich komme ja sonst nicht über die Runden. Das, so würde ich es machen.
Wobei, wobei, ist ja, um korrekt zu sein, 2021 sind es ja Streamerinnen, man muss das
ja, man muss das ja korrekt aussprechen, ne. Also manchmal übertreiben es die Leute
schon. Wow, ah nice, oh was hat der da für ein Dremel-Aufsatz, den finde ich Poggers,
das ist, dass es nicht so, nicht so, nicht so, nicht so spritzt ist das. Ey, der macht
es aber, der macht es aber professionell, also Leute, wisst ihr, wie das bei mir ausgesehen
hätte, ich hätte mal angenommen, ich hätte aus irgendwelchen Gründen den Raspberry Pi
Cluster bauen müssen mit Wasserkühlung, was ich nicht muss, aber wenn ich es hätte
machen müssen, ich hätte, ich hätte einen Wasserkühlungsblock genommen, hätte es drauf
gebappt, auf den Raspberry Pi, ohne Gehäuse, ohne Halterung, ohne alles, wahrscheinlich
hätte ich noch eine runde Klebeband rumgepappt und gut ist, oder Kabelbinder, ich hätte
es wahrscheinlich mit Kabelbinder festgemacht und dann hätte ich es nebeneinander geschmissen,
in irgendeine Ecke Strom reingesteckt und gut ist, und der macht es halt richtig ordentlich.
Guck mal hier, der will es voll wissen, Alter, guckt euch das mal an, wie das ist richtig
professionell hier.
Ach, der baut, der baut noch einen Rack, der baut quasi gerade einen Rack für sein Raspberry
Pi Cluster noch und dann im Zweifelfall auffüllen mit Heißkleber, wenn es nicht hält, ja.
Heißkleber ist eh die beste Erfindung für Elektronik Sachen, seitdem ich Heißkleber gekauft
hab, ich glaub ich hab schon vier dieser Stifte durch, vier dieser Klebestifte, wisst
ihr, also diese Klebepatronen, hab ich schon vier Stück durch jetzt für gebastelt, einfach
random, ich mach jetzt bei allem was nicht hält, Heißkleber drauf, bam, und dann bappts,
ich hab hinten im Hof eine Raspberry Pi Cam, um zu gucken, die verwende ich normalerweise
nicht, das ist eine Testgeschichte, um zu gucken, wie gut die Raspberry Pi Cam ist bei
Lowlight Situationen, und die hab ich draußen auf die Fensterbank gelegt und das USB Kabel
geht halt unterm Fenster durch, und ich hatte jetzt ein paar Mal schon das Problem, dass
wenn es zu windig war, dass dann quasi der Raspberry Pi mehr oder weniger geschwebt ist,
oder halb geschwebt ist am USB Kabel, ja, ich hab das Ding einfach in den Schrumpfschlauch
gemacht, zugemacht, und das Ding ist halt, wenn ordentlich Wind drüber geblasen ist,
ist der Raspberry Pi quasi geflogen, fast schon auf der Fensterbank, also das hab ich
jetzt gemacht, riesen, riesen batzen Heißkleber, ich hab die Fensterbank einfach kurz abgeputzt
an der Stelle, trocken gemacht, Heißkleber drauf gesprayt, über den Raspberry Pi auf
die Fensterbank, und jetzt ist einfach, also außen an die Fensterbank, und jetzt pappt
das einfach, und der Raspberry Pi bewegt sich nicht mehr, und das Gute ist, wenn der Heißkleber
hart ist, und man nimmt einen Schraubendreher oder so, und hebelt das ab, das geht dann
auch im Stück wieder weg, also du kriegst das sogar noch mehr, mehr oder weniger rückstandslos
weg, ja, also Raspberry Pi an der Fensterbank festgepappt mit Heißkleber, Heißkleber ist
das beste Erfindung, was hat der für einen Akkuschrauber, was ist das für einer, was
ist das für einer, ein GSR 18 ist das, ok, ok ist die Nummer größer als meiner, der
baut sich echt ein eigenes Rektor auf, jetzt färbt das auch noch, alter der übertreibt
es, der Kell übertreibt es echt, das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert, äh ausprobiert,
äh äh Joshi, du weißt was, ich habs für zwischenmännliche Beziehungen nicht so, ich
bin eigentlich froh, wenn nicht so viele Leute bei mir in der Nähe sind, dass ich meine Ruhe
habe, guckt euch das mal an, das macht richtig Spaß her, Kronix zwei Monate, danke schön
für den Sub, mich persönlich hätte jetzt gedrängert, dass ich mich hier verschnitten
habe, was ist das für ein mega Lüfter, das 12cm Lüfter mit 30.000 Flügeln, wie nennt
man das, Lamellen, wie heißt denn das beim Lüfter, die Fächer, 3,4,5,6,7,8,19,11,
12 Stück, Flugzeuge ja, hebt ab, Blätter, ja, Blätter, äh Rotorblatt, Rotorblätter,
ja Blätter, Chet, Chet weiß mit Abscheid, guck mal jetzt macht er sogar noch seine Schläuche
in richtigen Abmessungen und Abständen, gleich, gleich rotiert es ja, was sind das eigentlich
für Netzwerke, das ist ein übelst langer Netzwerkstecker oder, sieht das nur so aus,
als durchsichtiges, ein Display auch noch, warum genau ein Display, das wirst du doch
eh nur, wie Mod-Management, hast du eigentlich schon mal was mit Kubernetes, Rancher in der
Richtung gemacht, also wir haben CoreOS auf der Arbeit, auf manchen Kisten, damit habe
ich am Rande schon mal was gemacht und Kubernetes habe ich noch nie, das habe ich mir schon
mal, für die Ziele vorgenommen, noch nie komplett vom Scratch aufgebaut, ich habe
schon ein paar Dinge gestoppt, gestartet und gemacht, ja, aber ich habe noch nie den Kubernetes
da vorhanden aufgebaut, das wollte ich mal im Stream machen, dann nehmen wir vielleicht
wirklich, entweder nehmen wir 3 VMs und nehmen 3 Raspberry Pies oder so, Leonidas, 26 Tage
für den Sub, hat er RGB Beleuchtung, hat er RGBs, habe ich jetzt gar nicht gesehen,
war, oh Poggers, richtig, jetzt wird es etwas, ohne RGB Beleuchtung geht das natürlich auch
nicht, aber RGB, kein RGBW, also sprich, das RGB sieht zumindest hell nicht ganz so gut
aus, weiß, gleich Rechenleistung verdoppelt, mindestens verdoppelt, Moment, da muss doch
jetzt noch irgendeine Farbe rein, oder, zumindest das Licht muss passend angedingst werden, ja,
super, exzellent, RGBW, Wupp RGBW wäre eigentlich auch ein gutes E-Mode, das ist einfach, das
ist einfach ein Keks in 4 Farben dann, was macht er jetzt damit, da geht es ja bei solchen
Projekten nicht drum, da geht bei solchen Projekten geht es in der Regel ums Bauen
und dann ums haben und danach wieder auseinandernehmen, oder was auch immer, hinstellen und für nichts
verwenden können, Infinite Desk, Dankeschön Stufe 1, Subscription, das Gametrain ist am Start,
ja,
es ist echt cool, Anwendungszweck und Sinn wechseln, das ist echt cool, Anwendungszweck
und Sinn weniger vorhanden, aber geil ist es, der hat es auch wirklich hübsch gemacht,
guck mal das, das sieht wirklich cool aus, brauchen tut es keiner, aber cool ist es,
schön Eduard, dass du am Start bist, bist du von YouTube gekommen, oder wie hast du das
gefunden, weil ein paar Leute haben mich ja auch zufällig hier über Twitch gefunden,
nachdem auch das war, in den Twitch Empfehlungen und dann so hochmachst, den kenne ich doch
irgendwo her, was kann ich damit machen, ja haben und angucken, wie geil sichs dreht,
und du kannst ein Kubernetes Cluster drauf machen, nee, wie gesagt Musik ist ein schwieriges
Thema, erstens ist es auf YouTube so ein Ding, generell schwierig und man kann ja nirgends
mal Sound Samples rein machen, Leko, Poggers, also wenn einer, mein Lieblingsalbum der letzten
Jahre ist das da, das da, kann jetzt leider nichts abspielen, aber wenn einer mal bisschen
hier Headbanger Action haben will, das ist wirklich Pog, man darf hier leider nichts
mal abspielen, aber das ist wirklich nice, das ist echt so mein Lieblingsalbum der letzten
Jahre gewesen, Massive, also wer auf bisschen, auf etwas schnellere, härtere Sachen steht,
so ein bisschen Fantasy Kram, das ist echt nice, hast du die mal live gesehen, ja die
rennen ja in ein Kostüm auf der Bühne rum, ne, mittlerweile, auch das ist eine gute Frage,
kann man ganz einfach beantworten, bist ja mittlerweile schon etwas älter geworden,
Max, gibt es eine Berufsausbildung, welche du gerne gelernt hättest, jetzt so im Nachhinein,
was mit Holz, das verstehen wahrscheinlich nicht alle, aber ich glaube, ne also der Witz
mit Holz ist, es hat mir mal jemand beim Arbeitsamt empfohlen, ich soll was mit Holz lernen und
das war halt überhaupt nicht meins, ne, ehrlich gesagt hätte ich nichts anderes lernen wollen
als das, was ich gelernt habe, was hältst du vom neuen Raspberry Pi Pico, nix, das ist
ja kein Raspberry Pi im eigentlichen Sinn, das ist quasi so eine Art Arduino, allerdings
was dir fehlt ist WLAN, ohne WLAN sackt halt einfach solche Controller, dann nehme ich
einfach einen ESP32, hab wahrscheinlich mehr Libraries, mehr Support, mehr alles, ne also,
ja und was anderes lerne, ohne Mist, ich hätt nix anderes lernen wollen, Sauros Master, Twitch
Prime, 2 Monate, Dankeschön für die Sub, Massive Subscriptions hier, ne, und der Leko
hat 100, 200, 300, 400, 500, 5 Euro in Bits gegiftet, nice, und Harry274 hat abonniert
vor 3 Minuten, Dankeschön für den Sub, Infinite Deaths hab ich gar nicht gesehen hier auch
nochmal, Danke für den Sub, der Scam Train ist am Start, ja, guck mal der Scam Train
ist schon auf 78%, das ist Absicht, das ist, ich hab das absichtlich so gelassen, weil
ich hab rausbekommen, dass viele Leute, dass, diese, so ne, so ne, so ne, so diese Art Gambling
Faktor mögen, die gucken da einen halben Tag drauf, ich hab das in der Visitor Statistik
gesehen, die Leute gucken da einen halben Tag drauf und finden es geil, dass es sich
laufend aktualisiert, wenn du die günstigsten Preise wissen willst, musst du halt hier drauf
klicken, gut hier gibt es aktuell nur einen Anbieter, wenn du die günstigsten Preise
wissen willst, musst du halt drauf klicken, sagen wir mal hier da, da siehst du PC King
ist gerade am günstigsten, Alter was, das ist doch nicht, im Ernst, das Ding kostet
einfach 1000 Euro mehr, die haben sie doch nimmer all, wie gesagt, nix, dadurch dass
kein Wlan hat, zack. Ja, das ist nice, ich, wie gesagt, ich hab
hier auch angefangen, als ich schon ein bisschen älter war. Ich hoffe, das ist jetzt das Richtige,
was du hier rausgesucht hast, manchmal braucht man einfach ein bisschen dafür, bis man es
gecheckt hat, was man machen will, mir hat man empfohlen, was mit Gabelstapler zu machen,
nice, wie Gabelstapler Tim, ne, wie hieß dieses Video, dieses Gabelstapler, dieses Gabelstapler
Lernvideo, was, Gabelstapler Tim, Klaus, Klaus, Klaus, genau, Gabelstapler Klaus. Habt ihr
das mitgekriegt, das Semper Video gelöscht wurde, kann man es gerade noch mal kurz angucken,
die haben den Channel gelöscht, weil er 3 Strikes bekommen hat, wo man halt wieder das
Problem sieht, dass die YouTube-Regeln halt total, naja, so undurchsichtig sind, ne.
Hallo, in diesem Video nur ganz kurz ein kleiner Rückblick auf die letzten 24 Stunden. Dass
wir derzeit einige Probleme mit YouTube haben, das dürfte inzwischen bekannt sein, wenn nicht,
dann das entsprechende Video vom 18. Ich finde das, ich finde das geil, da spricht, da spricht
die ganzen, das macht der seit Jahren schon, da spricht die ganzen Begriffe immer so, so
übelst korrekt auf, ich bin ja jemand, der verschluckt zig Buchstaben in den Wörtern,
ich sag ja manchmal auch YouTube und sowas, der sagt immer auf YouTube, das ist auf YouTube,
der alles geübt. Keine Ahnung, haben.
Das ist wirklich fragwürdig, ne, muss man echt mal sagen, also, die Videos, die man
auf YouTube hochgeladen hat, vor 5 Jahren, die waren vollkommen in Ordnung mit den YouTube-Richtlinien,
wenn YouTube jetzt retroaktiv quasi das ändert, ist das, bin ich das schon ein bisschen fragwürdig
für die Videos und das nächste ist, dass die Regeln so geschrieben sind, dass man überhaupt
nicht genau greifen kann, was bedeutet, da steht zum Beispiel drin, Hacking ist nicht
erlaubt und dann total schwammig weiter ausformuliert, dass beispielsweise Educational Content ist
okay, aber Sachen, die irgendeinem Schaden zufügen, nicht, aber das ist halt auch so
weit gestreckt, ja, und das ist echt problematisch, aber man muss ja mal sagen, auf Twitch ist
es auch nicht besser, also auf Twitch sind ja gerade auch die Sperrungen und Buns und
Sachen, die es gibt, total inkonsistent, dann hast du die eine, die quasi, ja mal kurz
Plank in die Kamera hält und 3 Tage bekommt und irgendein anderer, der mit Freunden im
TS mal einen doofen Spruch gemacht hat, 7 Tage bekommt, das ist nicht ganz nachvollziehbar
alles, ja, aber ich mein, man hat's gesehen, auf Twitter haben sie Trump gebannt und ich
mein, jetzt könnt ihr euch mal überlegen, wenn man als Social Media Plattform den Kokona
President bannen kann und der sein Account nicht wiederkriegt, was soll denn der 0815
Twitch Benutzer machen dagegen, also wenn die quasi einen der einflussreichsten Leute
der Welt bannen können und nichts passiert und was soll denn der 0815 und der keine Möglichkeit
hat, was dagegen zu machen, was soll denn der 0815 Twitter User machen, der hat einfach
gelitten, ok, da muss ich jetzt mal was zu sagen, ich finde es nicht gut, dass Twitter
Trump gebannt hat, gar nicht wegen dem Inhalt, wegen dem Inhalt kann ich das voll und ganz
nachvollziehen, der Kerl hat so viel Schwachsinn von sich gegeben, aber bei mir ist es ein
ganz anderer Grund, warum ich es nicht gut finde, dass sie den gebannt haben oder generell
das überhaupt Twitter die Möglichkeit hat so jemand zu bannen, man darf nicht vergessen,
über die letzten hunderte Jahre von gesellschaftlicher Entwicklung haben sich ja so ein paar Dinge
rauskristallisiert, die ganz gut funktionieren, zum Beispiel, dass man gesagt hat, ok, die
Leute, die Gesetze machen sind andere, wie die Leute, die die Gesetze dann auslegen
und sind wieder andere, die dann bei dir in dein Haus einsteigen und dich rauszerren,
so nach dem Motto, also du hast einmal die Polizei, du hast Gerichte und du hast Gesetzgeber,
das gibt es bei Twitter nicht und das ist das eigentliche Problem, was ich da dran sehe,
wenn man so jemand wie Trump sperrt und quasi auch zeigt, dass man quasi im Endeffekt da
allmächtig ist in dieser Richtung, das ist eigentlich komplett entgegen dem, was sich
so die letzten paar hundert Jahre etabliert hat, was ich nicht gut finde, weil im Endeffekt
ist es bei Twitter so und es geht nicht darum, dass sie es dürfen, dürfen tun nichts, das
ist ihre Plattform, ob das eine sinnvolle Entwicklung ist, ist aber fragwürdig, muss
ich mal überlegen, wieviel Macht Twitter an dieser Stelle hat, also sprich, Twitter macht
die Gesetze, AGBs, was auch immer, TOS, Twitter entscheidet, wie diese Gesetze angewendet
werden, wie die ausgelegt werden, also sie machen Rechtsprechung auch noch und Twitter
bantig auch, das heißt im Endeffekt, Twitter hat alle Macht in der Hand, das ist halt ein
bisschen fraglich, ja und wisst ihr, was ich auch glaube, jetzt mal meine persönliche,
meine persönliche Ansprache, ich glaube gar nicht mal, dass Twitter Trump gebannt hat,
weil Trump Scheiße erzählt hat, das wäre ja noch irgendwie nachvollziehbar, aber Twitter
ist das ziemlich egal, ob Trump Scheiße erzählt oder nicht, weil wenn es danach gehen würde,
dann müsste man 90% von Twitter bannen, wenn es um Scheiße erzählen geht, Twitter ist das
ziemlich egal, Twitter hat das gemacht, um zu zeigen, dass sie der King sind, Quatsch,
es geht überhaupt nicht darum, ob es in diesem einen Fall gerechtfertigt ist, es geht um
die Art und Weise, wie viel Macht Twitter hat und was Twitter damit bezwecken will,
was will Twitter damit bezwecken, Twitter ist daran interessiert, wie alle Social-Media-Dinger
Money zu machen, Hauptsache dicke Kohle zu scheffeln, irgendwelche moralischen Sachen,
soziale Sachen ist Twitter vollkommen egal, es geht nicht darum, ob es berechtigt war
in diesem einen Fall oder nicht, das ist vollkommen egal, es geht darum, was Twitter damit machen
will, Twitter interessiert es doch nicht, Twitter ist es scheißegal, ob Trump Scheiße
postet oder ob du und ich Scheiße posten, der Fakt, dass jemand Scheiße postet, interessiert
Twitter nicht, Twitter interessiert Kohle zu verdienen und in dem Fall wollte Twitter nichts
anderes als zeigen, dass sie der Herr im Haus sind, das ist was Twitter wollte, Twitter
wollte sagen, wir sind die, die den Hut auf haben im Internet, ob das jetzt in diesem
einen Fall gerechtfertigt ist oder nicht ist vollkommen wurscht, Twitter will sagen, hier
wir haben das sagen und dass Twitter das so einfach kann, bei einem der einflussreichsten
Leute der Welt halte ich für fragwürdig, dass das möglich ist, tja. Twitter geht es
darum, erstens natürlich um gut dazu, ja was meint ihr, warum die das jetzt machen, was
meint ihr, warum die das jetzt machen, jetzt machen die das, weil sie dann auch noch Pluspunkte
sammeln, aber Twitter macht das nicht, weil die so von überzeugt sind, dass das richtig
ist, Twitter macht das, weil sie jetzt Pluspunkte damit sammeln bei den Leuten und weil Twitter
auf den Tisch schauen kann und sagen, guckt mal, was euch passieren kann, wenn ihr euch
mit uns anlegt, deswegen macht Twitter das. Und man darf auch nicht vergessen, dass quasi
zur letzten Wahl hat das ganze Social Media Zeug auch noch entscheidend dazu beigetragen,
dass Trump gewonnen hat, ja, das kommt ja auch noch dabei, da wo man schon wieder sieht,
letztendlich ist es Twitter scheißegal, Twitter geht es darum, Bonuspunkte zu sammeln und
um Kohle zu machen und die machen das, was sie denken, dass dafür das beste ist, unabhängig
von was die Welt moralisch interessiert, das ist Twitter scheißegal, Twitter interessiert
sich für Twitter, genauso wie sich Facebook für Facebook, das sind alles Stonks Leute,
ihr glaubt doch nicht ernsthaft, dass Stonks Leute auf einmal moralisch geworden sind,
das ist denen auch egal, der hätte vorher doch auch nicht wirklich was machen können
und das wollten die damit zeigen, Bäm, die wollten noch mal zeigen, wir haben hier das
sagen, wenn der Typ zu irgendeinem Scheißdreck aufruft, es rufen genug Leute zu Schwachsinn
auf Twitter auf, Twitter hat es gemacht, um Bonuspunkte zu sammeln und Twitter wollte
damit zeigen, dass sie daher im Haus sind und das sagen haben, das, ihr glaubt doch
nicht wirklich, dass irgendwelche Businessmanager Leute auf einmal sich da moralisch irgendwie
dafür verantwortlich fühlen, dann hätten die doch komplett, da müssten 90% der Leute,
wenn die Leute sich wirklich dafür verantwortlich fühlen würden, was auf Twitter gepostet
wird, dann müssten die 90% der Leute auf Twitter löschen, das ist denen egal, denen geht es
schlicht und ergreifend unterm Strich um Kohle und ums Gut Dastehen, was auch wieder bedeutet
mehr Kohle.
Ja und deswegen, gerade deswegen ist das fragwürdig, dass das überhaupt geht, also ich persönlich
finde es äußerst fragwürdig, wenn Twitter beispielsweise das Staatsoberhaupt einfach
bannen kann, natürlich können sie das, sie sind eine private Plattform, sie können das
machen, aber man darf nicht vergessen, in diesem Punkt, es ist auf einmal derjenige,
der die Gesetze macht, der die Gesetze auslegt und der die Gesetze quasi durchsetzt, ist
eine Person und das ist echt fragwürdig, wieviel Macht Twitter an der Position hat.
Das ist das einzige Problem, ob jetzt Trump gebannt, der Einzelfall ist mir ehrlich gesagt
ziemlich wurscht und das ist echt fragwürdig und Twitter wollte damit zeigen, hallo ich
bin der King und guckt mal was passiert.
Genau, das ist das eigentliche Problem und das ist das, was sich die letzten Jahrhunderte
so ein bisschen etabliert hat, ich mein, guckt mal nach Frankreich, nicht 1900, wann war
das, 1600, irgendwer oder so, da war es auch noch, oder 1700, ach frag mich nicht, lang
her, die hatten auch noch Könige, da war das so und das ist nicht sonderlich gut gelaufen,
die haben auch noch Könige, die haben alles gemacht, der Typ, im Prinzip ist das so,
Twitter kann sich hinstellen, ohne Begründung und sagen, ich banne dich jetzt, das ist ähnlich
wie damals irgendein König sagen könnte so, ja übrigens du darfst jetzt, ich verbanne
dich jetzt irgendwo hin.
Was ist da dran nicht zu verstehen, ich sag, dass es nicht gut ist, dass es keine Gewaltenteilung
auf Twitter gibt, so wie sich das über lange Zeit etabliert hat, Twitter kann im Endeffekt
komplett losgelöst irgendwie davon entscheiden und dass sie das mit Trump gemacht haben,
ist einfach, wie soll ich sagen, zeigen, dass sie der King sind und auch um zu zeigen, guckt
mal was passiert, wenn man sich mit uns anlegt und sie können Bonuspunkte machen, das ist
perfekt für Twitter, das ist perfekt für Twitter, jetzt der aktuelle Zeitgeist war
ja ziemlich anti-Trump in dem Fall, sie können Bonuspunkte machen bei den Leuten, dass sie
in bannen, man muss sich aber davon lösen, dass, ob es gerechtfertigt ist oder nicht,
das war es in dem Fall meinetwegen, dazu sage ich gar nichts dagegen, das ist gar nicht
der Punkt, ob es gerechtfertigt ist oder nicht, man muss sich fragen, was für eine Gewalt
Twitter ausüben kann in dem Fall, das ist das eigentliche und was man sich fragen muss
ist, also ich muss das anders sagen, ich habe das Gefühl, die Leute glauben, Twitter wäre
quasi, würde sich da verantwortlich fühlen oder Twitter hat das gemacht, weil Twitter
moralisch erkannt hat, es wäre nicht gut, was der Typ postet, das ist Twitter scheiß
egal.
Natürlich will Twitter Macht demonstrieren, das ist der einzige Grund, warum die das machen,
Twitter ist das moralisch doch vollkommen wurscht, was da einer postet, Twitter geht
es um Geldverdienen, das ist denen scheiß egal, das juckt die nicht, ihr meint doch
nicht, dass irgendein Manager Typ sich da hinstellt und morgen vor vier Jahren gesagt
hat, oh geil, Trump Social Media, ja wir helfen ihm quasi noch die Wahl zu gewinnen und vier
Jahre später auf einmal sagt, oh moralisch war das echt fragwürdig, wir bannen den Typ
jetzt.
Die haben das aus zwei Gründen gemacht, erstens, weil das gerade gut in den Zeitgeist gepasst
hat und man Bonuspunkte sammeln kann, weil man zeigen kann, hallo wir sind der King, guckt
was passiert, wenn ihr euch mit uns anlegt und unterm Strich, weil es mehr Kohle bringt,
die haben da keine Moral für, das ist denen auch vollkommen wurscht.
Das interessiert Facebook und Instagram, das übrigens der gleiche Land, das interessiert
die auch alle nicht, die machen nichts aus moralischen Gründen, ich mein, guckt euch
doch mal an, guckt euch mal Blizzard an zum Beispiel, da konntest du es wunderbar sehen,
Blizzard, Proteste in Hongkong, übelst den Schwanz eingezogen, noch nicht mal auf der
Blizzcon richtig was von sich gegeben, ja, so übelst rum, sich rumgedrückt, so irgendwie
so, ah nee, das geht ja nicht und sonst wie, wir trauen uns nicht und wir können ja nicht
unsere Sache in China vermarkten und sonst was, bei Black Life Matters waren sie dick
dabei.
Es geht in dem Fall nicht um die Frage, ob das gut oder schlecht ist, ob das Thema ist
rechtfertig oder nicht, man muss sich angucken, warum macht Blizzard das und das ist rein
wegen der Kohle und um gut dazustehen, die machen da nicht mit, weil sie sich moralisch
dazu verpflichtet fühlen oder sowas, einfach nur weil es ums Geld geht, ja, ja siehst
du noch im Chat, nein, das ist denen egal, Image und Kohle und Gebiet abstecken, der
Rest ist denen vollkommen wurscht, deswegen muss man sich auch von der eigentlichen Frage
lösen, ob es jetzt im konkreten Einzelfall gerechtfertigt war, ich hab gesagt, der Kerl
hat so viel Stumpfsinn geschrieben, man darf auch nicht mal vergessen, dass er erzählt
hat, dass die Leute irgendwie Desinfektionsmittel trinken sollen gegen Corona, der hat ultra
viel Bullshit geschrieben.
Wie gesagt, ich muss mich jetzt, ich muss mich ja nicht jetzt nochmal wiederholen, was
die eigentlichen Sachen sind, also wie gesagt, absolut wurscht, du kannst das persönlich
auch gut finden, genau, dass man das persönlich gut findet, ist jedem selbst überlassen,
ich finde nicht gut, also mir tut es um Trump nicht leid, dass der gebannt ist, ich finde
allerdings nicht gut, dass Twitter die Art und Weise an Machtausübung überhaupt machen
kann, die sie da haben, das heißt nämlich im Endeffekt, Twitter ist wichtiger als jede
andere Plattform, die haben damit im Endeffekt gesagt, ey guck mal, wenn du dich mit uns
anlegst, verlierst du das Sprachrohr zu Millionen von Leuten und da überlegt sich jemand anderes
zweimal was Sache ist, weil letztendlich überlegt euch mal, als wäre nicht Trump gewesen, überlegt
euch mal, die würden unsere Bundeskanzlerin sperren, die könntet auch nichts dagegen
machen, oder dich oder mich, du hast keine Chance im Endeffekt, das ist das eigentliche
Problem, Twitter kann die Regeln machen, Twitter kann die Regeln auslegen und Twitter kann
die Regeln durchsetzen, wie sie wollen, keine Ahnung ob die Twitter hat, in dem Fall ist
es Trump gewesen, deswegen finden das die Leute gut, wie gesagt, mir tut es um Trump
nicht leid, aber die Leute finden es gut, weil sie was dagegen hatten, ich weiß gar
nicht ob die Twitter hat, kann die überhaupt Twitter verwenden, bin ich mir nicht sicher,
Twitter macht die AGBs, das ist doch gerade der Punkt, Twitter legt die AGBs aus und Twitter
entscheidet ob du dagegen verstoßen hast, das ist genau der Punkt, es ist auch vollkommen
egal, ob du gegen die AGBs verstößt oder nicht, die ganzen Nutzungsbedingungen, wir
sind ja übrigens von einem YouTube Video, wo ein Channel gebannt wurde, die ganzen Nutzungsbedingungen
sind so geschrieben, dass du alles machen kannst, lest euch mal die Nutzungsbedingungen
teilweise durch, die sind so schwammig, du kannst alles, du kannst alles bannen, wenn
du heute keinen Bock drauf hast, du bist komplett allmächtiger Herrscher auf Twitter, wenn du
es so willst, nein, Twitter muss ich nicht, wenn es in den AGB, an welche Gesetze muss
ich Twitter dann bitte schön halten beim Account löschen, Twitter lösch dich jetzt,
was machst du, dann verklagst du dann Twitter, willst du dann Twitter verklagen, wenn die
dich löschen, du kannst, du kannst, ja mach, mach viel Spaß, mach das, mach das, da bin
ich, da bin ich aber gespannt, da bin ich aber echt gespannt, ja gut, das wäre ja noch
schöner, das wäre ja noch schöner, wenn Twitter sich nicht an irgendwelche Gesetze
halten müsste, aber im umgedrehten Fall kann Twitter für ihre Plattform eigene Gesetze
zusätzlich eigene Gesetze erstellen, die können bannen, wenn sie wollen, Twitter kann
bannen, wenn sie wollen, ja, das ist auch so, warum Twitter dich bannen wollte, vielleicht
weil irgendein Algorithmus festgestellt hat, du hast illegalen Content gepostet, was auch
immer, kann auch sein, von heute auf morgen ist dein Account weg und du kannst nichts
dagegen machen, also die Macht existiert bei Twitter, das ist kein Ding und das ist eigentlich
mein hauptsächlicher Kritikpunkt daran, nicht dass sie Trump gebannt haben oder sonst was,
der juckt mich persönlich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, wie gesagt, der Kerl hat viel Mist
erzählt, wenn der Tag lang ist, aber man sieht, wo die Reise hingeht und man darf nicht vergessen,
dass Twitter und generell Social Media, dass das eigentlich das wichtigste Kommunikationsmittel
der heutigen Zeit ist und du kannst von heute auf morgen ausgeschlossen werden und das nicht
nur auf Twitter, es ist ja dann oftmals so, dass das auch noch mehrfach, mehrfach passiert,
dass du dann im Zweifelsfall nicht nur von Twitter ausgeschlossen wirst, dass du dann
auch Amazon nicht mehr haust und so was und jeder, der das gut findet, der soll sich mal
fragen, geht es ihm, überwiegt er jetzt der einzelne Fall oder findet er das wirklich
nicht bedenklich, dass man quasi ultimative Macht auf der Plattform hat?
Ja gut, wie gesagt, das mit moralisch hatten wir schon abgehandelt, Twitter ist moral vollkommen
egal, genauso wie das übrigens Facebook, Instagram und allem Möglichen auch vollkommen
egal ist, ja, nein, das bringt überhaupt nichts, das bringt überhaupt gar nichts, dann ändert
YouTube die AGBs und kann dich trotzdem bannen, du wirst auf der Plattform verlieren, du wirst
dagegen verlieren auf der Plattform, im Endeffekt können die machen, was sie wollen und warum
können sie das machen, es ist doch ganz logisch, warum sie das machen können, sie schreiben
die Gesetze, sie wenden die Gesetze an und sie führen das durch, sie sind quasi alles
in einem auf ihrer Plattform, du hast keine Chance dagegen und ob das jetzt dir und mir
passiert, fraglich, Twitter wird sich wahrscheinlich nicht dafür interessieren, aber es kann potenziell
jedem passieren und dass das so ist finde ich nicht gut, so, um Trump geht es mir überhaupt
nicht, gut wunderbar, exzellent, jetzt haben wir das Thema auch mal besprochen, ich finde
man muss sich einfach mal davon lösen, ob Twitter, dass Twitter oder generell Firmen
da im Internet Social Media mäßig oder medien mäßig, dass die irgendwas machen, aus moralischen
Gründen, das ist denen vollkommen egal, genau, Twitter muss sich an Gesetze halten, aber
Twitter kann auch zusätzliche Gesetze machen, die auf ihrer Plattform gelten, Twitter könnte
zum Beispiel, umsetzt mal auf die Spitze, umsetzt mal sagen, wie abstrus das ganze ist und es
geht jetzt auch nicht darum, ob sie es machen oder nicht, Twitter könnte oder YouTube könnte,
oder auch immer, könnte sagen, ab morgen darf das Wort UND nicht mehr verwendet werden,
das können nicht die AGBs schreiben, ab morgen darf das Wort UND nicht mehr verwendet werden,
tristrikesban, bäm, ist total abstrus, aber das könnten sie machen, werden sie nicht
machen, weil sie in dem Fall natürlich bescheuert ist, so eine Regel zu machen, weil du dann
alle Benutzer löschen müsstest und Twitter nicht mehr relevant wäre, das könnten die
im Endeffekt machen, das wäre kein Ding, das könnten die auf ihrer Plattform durchsetzen
und du kannst, du hast vielleicht theoretische, theoretische Möglichkeiten irgendwie dagegen
vorzugehen, aber was willst du machen?
Ja nur, dass dein lokaler Rewe für die öffentliche, für den öffentlichen Austausch nicht so
relevant ist wie Social Media, es geht auch nicht darum, dass das rechtlich, dass sie
das nicht dürfen, natürlich, mein Punkt ist doch, sie dürfen es, das sage ich dir
die ganze Zeit, das ist ja das eigentliche Problem da dran, genau und Twitter ist alles
in einem, Twitter ist quasi König auf Twitter und du kannst da realistisch gesehen auch
nichts gegen machen und natürlich, und das möchte man mit dem Bann von Trump nochmal
betonen, möchte sagen Leute, wir haben den Hut auf, moralische Gründe spielen da überhaupt
keine Rolle, das ist Twitter scheißegal, so, exzellent, wer kenne ich der Millionensprache
auf Rewe Parkplatz?
Beim Rewe Parkplatz ist es jetzt so, da steht ein großes Schild, du musst beim Auto verlassen
schon deine Maske aufziehen und dann habe ich festgestellt, das geht gar nicht, weil
ich habe hinten, also hinten in der Tür, habe ich die Einkaufstasche stecken mit dem Zeug
und da musste ich tatsächlich aussteigen und hinten ins Auto gehen und dann konnte
ich mir die Maske erst aufziehen, ich hoffe ich kriege jetzt kein Rewe-Bann, so kam ab
dem Rewe eingefallen, ja, ist so, na nur mit dem Unterschied ist, nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass hier Twitch immer noch das Sagen hat letztendlich, wenn Twitch jetzt sagt, Max
wir bannen dich von heute auf morgen, ich könnte im Endeffekt nichts viel dagegen machen.
Zum Glück, zum Glück kann Twitter nur die Gesetze auf Twitter beeinflussen und nicht
die Vorgaben außerhalb, äh, weil ich das so eine Angewohnheit habe, das zu machen,
da gibt es Rewe-Perma-Bann, ja, so könnte man, what the fuck, so könnte man das ungefähr
zusammenfassen Florian, ja, äh, sagt mir nichts, so könnte, so könnte, so könnte
man das ungefähr zusammenfassen, ja, das heißt ja nicht, dass es gut ist, gerade wenn
man sich anguckt, wie wichtig die ganze Social-Media-Geschichte ist, natürlich ist das so, es ist ja auch nicht
so, dass das verboten wäre, die dürfen das ja, weißt, schön, dass du die Wege hier
hergefunden hast, ja, und vieles, vieles, was, ähm, offline gilt, gilt für Twitter
beispielsweise nicht, also zum Beispiel die Bahn muss dich befördern, die Bahn kann nicht
einfach sagen, du darfst nicht mitfahren, die Bahn darfst das nur machen, wenn du quasi
wiederhol-schwarz gefahren bist und sie beschützten hast oder sowas, für Twitter ist das egal,
Leko was habe ich, was habe ich übersehen, können wir nicht paar Smart-Home, doch, was
denn, welche denn, können wir, können wir, ich weiß bloß nicht, was jetzt gerade, wo
haben wir übrigens aufgehört, genau, ich wollte mir das Semper-Video angucken, das
gucken wir uns jetzt kurz noch an, was da, was da gelaufen ist, da sieht man vielleicht
auch ein bisschen die Problematik dabei.
Und deswegen entsprechend falsch, nach unserer Ansicht, entschieden haben, wie ebenfalls
in dem Video gesagt, ist es nur eine Frage der Zeit gewesen, bis wir den dritten Stryke
erhalten haben und dann ist der Channel futsch und um das zu vermeiden, haben wir rund 1000
Videos gelöscht, allerdings, äh, wussten wir natürlich nicht, ob das reicht, weil
YouTube bei der Bestimmung der Videos in Bezug auf, ja den gibt es wieder, der wurde jetzt
gebannt, weil er den dritten Stryke bekommen hat für ein Video, was uralt ist, gefährliche
Inhalte, all das alles in dem anderen Video, genau, weil YouTube jetzt, das ist auch so,
das ist genau so ein Punkt, den ich eben angesprochen habe, du kannst ein Video hochgeladen haben
vor 5 Jahren und heute, 5 Jahre später, fleckt YouTube dein Video für gefährlicher Inhalt
nach gut dünken und du hast keine Chance, du kannst im Endeffekt nichts machen, du kannst
auf ein bisschen Shitstorm hoffen, dass deine Follower auf Twitter, Instagram, sonst wo
YouTube voll spammen und sich das mal ein kompetenter Mensch anguckt und sagt, hey,
war ja gar nicht so, aber im Endeffekt, du bist auf G'day und Verderben der Sache ausgeliefert
und das ist halt der Punkt, den ich fragwürdig finde, in Bezug auf, welche Wichtigkeit mittlerweile
diese Plattformen haben, dass es dort quasi immer noch, dass dort immer quasi der König
regiert überall.
Das ist natürlich bei eurem lokalen Rewe auch so, allerdings ist euer lokaler Rewe vielleicht
so für den internationalen Informationsaustausch nicht so relevant.
Die entsprechenden Regeln sind natürlich...
Und meiner persönlichen Meinung nach ist eh deutlich zu viel, was da abgeht, Social
Media technisch mittlerweile in der heutigen Zeit.
Es müssten sich nicht 80 Millionen Leute oder 150 Millionen Leute weltweit empören, weil
einer was falsches in einem Tweet geschrieben hat oder so, aber so ist es mittlerweile und
dadurch sieht man eben, wie wichtig diese Plattformen geworden sind.
Und deswegen finde ich, das ist der Punkt, was ich fragwürdig finde, dass dort quasi
immer noch der König regiert, obwohl das so eine gesellschaftlich relevante Geschichte
ist.
Und dass es so ist, wollten sie mit dem Trump-Bunnen beweisen, den ging es nicht um irgendwelche
moralischen Dinger.
Das muss man sich mal generell bei solchen Firmen abschminken, dass es da immer irgendeine
moralische Entscheidung gibt.
Genau, neue Videos wurden wegen Hacking geflaggt, man muss sich mal die Videos von Semper-Video
angucken, dass das unter Hacking, Alter, dann müsstest du auch alle Capture the Flag-Leute
-Bunnen und alle Competitive Coder-Bunnen und sowas in der Richtung.
Es ist halt total inkonsistent und YouTube ist ja auch oder generell Twitch und wer auch
immer und Twitter, die sind ja auch nicht dazu gezwungen, das in irgendeiner Art und
Weise nachvollziehbar zu machen.
Die machen das hier sogar absichtlich vage, dass du nicht dagegen vorgehen kannst.
Habt ihr bis heute irgendwann mal gehört, warum Doktor Disrespect beispielsweise gebunnt
wurde?
Mich würde es echt mal interessieren, wirst du wahrscheinlich nie erfahren, aber da muss
ich sagen, der hat uns auch Bullshit erzählt, ich glaube, der weiß es, der sagt es bloß
nicht.
Aber dass da gar nichts durchsickert, das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Die haben ihn wieder Restored, Semper-Video wurde gelöscht und ist jetzt wieder da.
Wir gucken uns das Video jetzt an.
Doch, doch, guckst dir an, man wird grundlos gebannt, guckst dir an.
Da regiert der König und wenn der König sagt, du bist weg, dann bist du weg.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, warum YouTube das macht?
YouTube macht das nicht aus moralischen Gründen, wo wir gerade wieder beim Thema sind, weil
ich habe ja gesagt, die entscheiden das nicht aus moralischen Gründen, die machen das dem
Geld wegen.
Die bannen nicht Semper-Video dem Geld wegen, weil sie es wissen, die bannen das, weil irgendein
Algorithmus im Hintergrund sagt, oh guck mal, da ist eventuell irgendwas fishy, lass mal
lieber bannen, bevor uns Kohle durch die Lappen geht oder bevor wir einen riesen Shitstorm
bekommen, bevor Advertiser wegrennen oder sonst was.
Wir bannen lieber mal auf gut Glück, letztendlich unterm Strich, wegen Kohle.
YouTube geht es da auch nicht um irgendwelche moralischen Sachen, nie.
Ich glaube, das ist der Punkt, wo man sich irgendwie mal davon lösen muss, dass da irgendwie
einer was aus moralischen Gründen macht.
Auch Playstation und Xbox oder Blizzard oder irgendwelche Spielehersteller, die sich immer
so übelst rumschleimen, so nach dem Motto, wir haben die besten Fans und die loyalsten
und Gameplay First und wir hören auf die Community, es ist alles berechnetes Gelaber, um Geld zu
machen.
Denen geht es nicht um die Fans, wem es um die Fans geht, ist vielleicht ein Programmierer
der da sitzt und sich Gedanken um das Spiel macht oder irgendeinen Spieldesigner, aber
nicht die Leute, die den Kram entscheiden.
Und dass CD Projekt Red so viel Geld gemacht hat, mit äh, wobei ich den noch nicht mal
von Anfang an was Böses unterstellen würde, liegt einfach daran, die hatten einen richtig
guten Ruf.
Die haben Witcher 3 gemacht, die Leute haben gesagt, geil, wird vorbestellt, wird gemacht
und die haben jetzt einfach die Vorbestellung reingecashed.
Ja, beim nächsten Game wird das garantiert auch nicht mehr so gut funktionieren.
Ja, wer sich dafür wirklich interessiert, ist irgendein Indie-Entwickler auf Steam,
dem sein Spiel 10 Leute gekauft haben und wenn du ihm eine Bewertung hinschreibst oder
was ins Forum schreibst, der freut sich ein Ast ab, der interessiert sich dafür.
Aber Bobby Dings, wie heißt der Activision Typ, Bobby Kotnik, den juckt das doch nicht,
dem gehts um, also exklusiv um Stonks und vor allem seine eigenen Stonks.
Twitter geteilt und unsere Twitter-Follower, die haben dann unter anderem koordiniert das
YouTube-Team angesprochen auf Twitter.
Guck, YouTube ist da nur drauf aufmerksam geworden, weil die Leute ein bisschen geshitstormt
haben.
Dass das YouTube-Team dann auf diese ganze Geschichte aufmerksam geworden ist und uns
dann über Twitter zusagte, ein Experte würde sich den Fall nochmal anschauen.
Ein Experte.
Dann, wieder ein paar Stunden später, war der Kanal wieder verfügbar, auch darüber
haben wir keine E-Mail erhalten und wissen immer noch nicht, welches Video angeblich
gegen die YouTube-Richtlinien verstoßen haben soll.
Jetzt haben wir also den gleichen Stand wie vorher, die sind noch nicht mal verpflichtet,
zu ihm das zu sagen.
Wieder unsere zwei Strikes und unterm Strich kann man natürlich froh sein, dass man den
Kanal zurück hat und wir bedanken uns da auch nochmal ausdrücklich bei allen Twitter-Followern,
die sich da für uns eingesetzt haben, dass der Kanal wieder freigeschaltet wird.
Wer sich aber jetzt über das ganze hin und her wundert, von wegen, wieso sperrt YouTube
erst und dann schaut sich ein Experte an und dann wird der Kanal wieder freigeschaltet,
ja, da stellt man sich die Frage, wer hat sich denn vorher das Ganze angeschaut und
war auch...
Ein Experte natürlich, was sonst?
...konnte der erste Experte dann überhaupt eben das ganze sperren, ist das nicht der
gleiche?
YouTube hat sicherlich nur Experten.
Alles, alles voller Experten.
Ich sag euch aber mal ernsthaft, in so einem Content, so einer, wie heißt denn das, so
einer Upload-Kontrollier, moin, der Cute-Model ist am Start, in so einer Content-Kontrollier-Abteilung,
da möchte ich nicht arbeiten wollen, ne?
Also, das ist, was man da sieht, will ich mir eigentlich gar nicht angucken.
Experte gibt es Unterschiede bei Experten, Fragen oder Fragen, und ich gehe davon aus...
Du kannst da, Gundi, ich muss mir das Video nicht angucken, also wenn es um das Video
geht, wo jetzt einer erzählt, so nach dem Motto, er hat geklagt gegen YouTube, okay,
du kannst davon ausgehen, YouTube wird daraus gelernt haben und in Zukunft werden sie diesen
Fehler nicht mehr machen.
...dass sie das Video vom 28.12. gesehen haben, ansonsten Link in der Beschreibung.
Aus dem ganzen Hin und Her wird aber ein recht deutliches Bild, wenn man etwas weiter zurückschaut.
Vor drei oder vier Jahren, da hatte YouTube mal ziemliche Schwierigkeiten mit Videos,
die definitiv geeignet oder ungeeignet sind.
Da gab es doch Leute, die Tierquäler-Videos hochgeladen haben, die monetarisiert waren
und sowas, das war auch ein riesen Shitstorm für YouTube, was wollen die nicht nochmal
haben, sowas.
Das kann ich auch verstehen, dass Upload-Kontrollierer-Sachen, dass die outgesourced werden, weil den Kram
will wahrscheinlich keiner mehr machen, das lassen die jetzt wahrscheinlich irgendwelche
Chinesen im Container kontrollieren, die einen Cent die Stunde kriegen oder so und
ich glaube, ich habe letztes Mal einen Artikel darüber gelesen, dass irgendwie eine Mitarbeiterin
vom indischen Upload-Filter-Dings, die hat Angstzustände entwickelt durch die Videos,
das ist nicht ohne, was da für eine Scheiße hochgeladen wird.
Also, dass YouTube was nicht machen kann, weil irgendwas im Grundgesetz steht, da würde
mich ja mal interessieren, natürlich kann YouTube in seine AGBs verschreiben.
Ich meine, du darfst da nichts reinschreiben, was klar gegen das Grundgesetz verstößt,
du kannst das durchaus sehr vage und großflächig formulieren, was da in den AGBs drin steht,
dass du faktisch jedes Video löschen kannst, was aus welchen Gründen auch immer jetzt
gelöscht werden muss.
Und sollte sich YouTube an Gesetze halten, die in Deutschland gelten, dann nur weil ihnen
der deutsche Markt in irgendeiner Art und Weise wichtig ist, müssten die das wahrscheinlich
schon mal gar nicht, und wo im Grundgesetz willst du irgendwie regeln, dass sich YouTube
nicht bannen darf?
Also, ich kenne jetzt diesen konkreten Fall nicht, aber der Revo bei dir um die Ecke,
wenn du kann auch sagen, ja, sie haben sich nicht ordentlich benommen, sie dürfen nicht
mehr rein, klar, da kannst du dagegen klagen, du kannst auch gegen YouTube klagen, aber
du wirst da in 99% der Fälle keine Chance haben und im 1% der Fälle, und das ist ja
gerade das Problem, was ich damit habe, und im 1% der Fälle, wo man wirklich vielleicht
mal rechtlich, falls da einer was dagegen macht und wirklich damit durchkommen sollte,
dann lernen die Plattformen auch daraus, dass das nicht mehr vorkommt, dass das angepasst
wird und gut ist.
Die Leute, du hast zum größten Teil, das ist ja das Problem, was ich habe, dass die
eben zu viele Rechte haben, und bei den meisten Leuten, die haben auch schlicht und ergreifend
keine Chance.
Also, das muss halt schon was ganz Ausgefallenes gewesen sein, dass das funktioniert hat.
Stimmt, da kann ich mich auch noch dran erinnern, also mir persönlich, gerade in Anbetracht,
wie wichtig Social Media für die soziale Kommunikation, welche gesellschaftliche Relevanz
Social Media hat, wäre ich persönlich schon ein Fan davon, dass dort eben nicht, zumindest
bei den großen Plattformen, nicht mehr der König regiert, sondern es eine Gewaltenteilung
in welcher Art und Weise gibt.
Natürlich wirst du es nicht rausbekommen, dass YouTube und Twitter und wer auch immer
auf ihren Plattformen letztendlich das Sagen hat, aber es wäre ja schon mal cool, wenn
man das irgendwie gesetzlich regelt, dass gewisse Prozesse befolgt werden müssen.
Ja, also dass man jetzt zum Beispiel sagt, ok, es gibt gewisse Dinge, die wären nicht
gültig, wenn sie in den AGB stehen oder dass man einen Grund dafür erfahren muss, warum
man gebannt wird, dass man ein geregeltes Einspruchverfahren hat, was dann auch nachvollziehbar
ist.
Irgendwas, da kann man sicherlich viel machen, das wird mir persönlich gefallen.
Ne, da muss ich dir sagen, das sehe ich anders, ich bin ja da prinzipiell für Vertragsfreiheit
und alles und ja, du musst das nicht verwenden, aber es gibt nun mal unterm Strich, sagen
wir mal fünf große Dinge, die unglaublich relevant sind, sei es YouTube, Facebook für
die Boomer Generation, für Instagram, Twitch, Snapchat, es gibt so fünf, sechs riesen
Dinge, die gesellschaftlich so relevant sind, wo man sich da wirklich mal Gedanken drüber
machen muss, was das in dem Fall bedeutet, wenn die einfach machen können, was sie wollen
und dadurch, wie gesagt, gerade dadurch, dass Trump gebannt wurde, siehst du, sie können
faktisch machen, was sie wollen.
In dem Fall war es natürlich gefundenes Fressen für Twitter, Twitter konnte sagen, ok, aktuell
ist die Lage eh relativ anti-Trump, also können wir den bannen, ohne dass wir einen
riesen Shitstorm befürchten müssen, wir machen Pluspunkte bei vielen Leuten dafür
und außerdem kommt noch dazu, dass man das auch gut rechtfertigen kann, weil der hat
ja auch viel Blödsinn gepostet, ah, das war easy, das war easy, da konnte man mal ein
bisschen Muskel spielen lassen, um zu sagen, guck mal hier, wir haben das sagen und nicht
ihr.
Wie vor, man weiß jetzt wieder, sechs Jahren, fünf Jahren angefangen haben, alles zu monetarisieren,
was nicht hatte.
Aber guck mal, wie hilflos Semper-Video in dem Fall gewesen wäre, hätten die Leute
nicht Alarm auf Twitter gemacht, at YouTube, wäre sein Channel jetzt weg gewesen.
Da er auf der Palme war, ganz am Anfang war das so, da waren die auch mit dabei, da musste
man sich bei YouTube bewerben, um Partner zu werden und dann hat sich, zumindest in unserem
Fall war das damals eine junge Dame, zumindest von der Stimme her, die hat sich dann unsere
Videos angeschaut und hat dann gemeint, ok, warum sollten die Videos jetzt Partner werden,
haben wir der Frau erklärt und die Frau hat dann nachher irgendwann gesagt, ok.
Ich hatte zu Uhrzeit, ich hatte auch mal mit irgendeinem Luke von YouTube Kontakt, 2010
fragt mich nicht, zehn oder so.
Ihr Partner, dann alle Videos, die wir hochgeladen haben, die hat sich die Frau.
Damals hatten YouTube-Mitarbeiter noch echte Namen und das waren auch wirklich echte Personen.
Angeschaut und dann eben von Hand freigeschaltet und nach drei bis vier Wochen hatte die so
den Kanal voll, weil wir so viele Videos hochgeladen haben, dass sie dann gesagt hat, ok, ich hab
euch jetzt lange noch beobachtet, ihr seid da, ich sag mal seriös und ihr seid jetzt
vollständiger Partner.
So weit, so gut und so lief das dann auch mit vielen anderen Partnern, jedenfalls zu
der ersten Zeit.
Der Provokateur, denke ich, ist es auf jeden Fall, ja.
Ich hab aber gemeint, dass man noch viel mehr Geld verdienen könnte, wenn man jetzt auch
noch sogenannte Monetarisierungspartner akzeptiert, also eigentlich gar keine Partner, sondern
nur zum Geld machen, da sind dann eben nämlich auch die Uploader mit dabei, die nur ein Video
hochgeladen haben, zum Beispiel.
Funny Meme Compilation oder irgendwie Funny Cat macht Funny Things.
Tanzenden Baby zu irgendeinem Beyoncé Song oder so.
Peng, war auf einmal das Video, ein monetarisiertes Video und der Kanal eben dann, ja, aber nur
Monetarisierungspartner.
Das war für YouTube einfach, denn die haben natürlich damit jeden zum Partner gemacht,
der innerhalb von kurzer Zeit 10.000 Klicks auf einem Video versammelt hatte, deswegen
hatte man dann am Ende ja auch Werbung von einem ISIS-Video, denn naja, das hatte halt
genug Klicks.
Ja, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, da kann ich schon dran erinnern.
Anele.
Das hat also für entsprechend schlechte Nachrichten gesorgt und YouTube hatte jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten,
zum einen auf jeden Fall sich...
Basti, ich wollte das auch nicht vergleichen, das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Paar
Schuhe.
Die einzige Sache, die die gemeint haben, ist, dass es unterm Strich sowohl YouTube als auch
Twitter um Kohle geht.
Und nur richtige Partner zu monetarisieren oder eben einher von Zuschauern zu nutzen,
die solche Videos flägen sollen.
Ja.
Natürlich setzt YouTube auch KI ein um ungeeignete...
Und die haben ihre Upload-Filter in da, die das nicht länger als ein paar Monate machen
können, weil sie Albträume von kriegen.
Man darf sich mal nicht überlegen, also man muss sich mal überlegen, was da auch für
eine Scheiße hochgeladen wird.
Ich würde das auch nicht machen wollen, ganz ehrlich, ich würde im Leben nicht arbeiten
wollen bei diesem YouTube-Upload-Kontrollier-Stream.
Also, nicht Stream, Team, was du dir da für eine Scheiße angucken musst, Alter, ich
weiß es nicht, aber ich kann es mir nur ausmalen, ja, dass da Leute angekackt werden, ist wahrscheinlich
noch das Harmloseste dabei, also da ist wahrscheinlich alles dabei, von illegalen Sachen bis einfach
nur abartige Sachen, bis Sachen, wo du es mit der Angst zu tun kriegst, da ist wahrscheinlich
einfach alles dabei, was du dir da angucken musst, ja, und dass die Albträume davon bekommen
und irgendwelche traumatischen Dinge haben, danach kann ich mir wirklich gut vorstellen.
Da wird ja YouTube meiner Meinung nach auch zurecht vorgeworfen, dass man nicht richtig
mit den Leuten umgeht, die sich quasi den Klo auslöffeln dürfen, so.
Aber diese KI schaut niemals nach hinten, die KI schaut sich immer nur die Videos an,
die gerade hochgeladen werden, wenn das Video gleich hochgeladen wird, dann schaut sich
die KI das an über Titel, die KI scannt die Tonspur und hört dazu, jedenfalls die ersten
zwei, drei Minuten, wenn ich das richtige in Erinnerung habe, ansonsten die Metatags,
die Beschreibung und so weiter, das wird alles geprüft auf entsprechende Schlüsselwörter
und dann wird entweder schon von vorne rein gesagt, also hier gibt es keine Ahnung, das
ist alles outsourced, oder eben, ja, das Video ist okay, also die KI schaut drauf, aber immer
nur bei den Videos, die jetzt hochgeladen werden, nicht bei den Videos, die zum Beispiel vor
fünf Jahren hochgeladen wurden.
Ja gut, ja klar, die machen, das ergibt ja auch Sinn, du kontrollierst das nach aktuellen
Maßstäben des Aktuellen, du kannst ja schlecht Billiarden Content durchsuchen, der bis zu,
frag mich nicht, 15 Jahre alt ist oder so.
Dieses System, wenn man eben Videos hochgeladen hat, die ein Musikintro haben und nachher
hat sich rausgestellt, das Musikintro, das war doch nicht so frei, wie uns damals versprochen
wurde, ein anderer ist hingegangen, hat das rechtmäßig geklämt, also das Lied, da sind
alle Videos von uns betroffen, die hochgeladen wurden, seitdem er geklämt hat, die 12 Jahre
davor, die sind alle nicht geklämt, also das interessiert mich.
Warum nicht alte Sachen löschen ohne Strike, das wäre eine gute Möglichkeit, was noch
besser wäre, alte Sachen flecken und eventuell unlisted oder private machen und eine Benachrichtigung
schicken, dann könnte man sich das nämlich mal angucken, das wäre sinnvoll, aber gut,
warum sie das nicht machen ist wahrscheinlich relativ easy, wahrscheinlich, weil es Kohle
kostet.
Das ist die Lösung, die YouTube für sich ausgesucht hat, die das beste Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis
bietet und unterm Strich wieder stonkst.
Naja, speziellen Partnern mehr Vertrauen entgegenbringen, das ist das, was ich jetzt
entgegenbringen kann, schwierig, ihr könnt euch doch noch an das Video erinnern, welcher
war das für ein Ding, Jake Paul, der mit dem Suizidwald-Video und sowas, ja, da wird auch
viel Schwachsinn hochgeladen, nicht Logan Paul, ich kann mir die Typen nicht merken.
Logan Paul, nicht Jake Paul, gibt es Jake Paul nicht auch?
Na gut, Jake und Paul ist ein Name, den gibt es wahrscheinlich millionenfach.
Das ein Nutzer das meldet und unsere Videos werden regelmäßig gefleckt, das wissen wir,
das steht ja auch mehr oder weniger in unseren Kommentaren.
Es gibt immer einen gewissen Prozentsatz an Zuschauern, wir nennen sowas hier die Blockwart-Abteilung,
die verstehen einfach die Inhalte nicht oder was weiß ich, machen sich Sorgen.
Eigentlich unsere Videos erhalten eine Zustimmung mit Daumen nach oben, in der Regel von 95%
oder mehr.
Das ist zum Beispiel ein Parameter, der bei YouTube überhaupt keine Rolle spielt, aber
die 5% die das Video nicht gut finden, die machen halt in Anführungsstrichen Probleme,
denn da sind einige dabei, die das Gezeigte einfach nicht verstehen.
Wenn wir in einem Video zeigen, wie zum Beispiel Click-Tracking funktioniert, dann zeigen
wir das, damit der Zuschauer es versteht und dann am Ende sicher damit umgehen kann.
Jemand, der sich allerdings die Hose mit einer Kneifzange zu macht, versteht das Video nicht,
der sieht den Unterland abendlandes aufziehen und meldet eben das Video.
Vielleicht meldet er einfach auch nur das Video, weil er schlecht drauf ist und weil
er es nicht versteht, weil es gibt unglaublich viele richtig dumme Leute auf YouTube.
Zum Glück haben wir hier das Problem nicht.
Allerdings, dann schaut sich ein YouTube-Mitarbeiter das Ganze an und der ist auch nicht viel mehr
in der Sache drin und sagt sich wahrscheinlich, also ich verstehe nicht mal, was der da erzählt,
der Typ, und der andere hat mir aber gesagt, das ist irgendwie gefährlicher Inhalt, ja
gut, ich will ja jetzt hier auch keinen Stress kriegen, indem ich das Video jetzt online
lasse und nachher passiert da irgendwas, also Overblocking.
An unsub macht man heute nicht, man macht heutzutage Dis-Abo.
Relativ einfach.
Gut, dann nehme ich das Video jetzt einfach mal raus, was soll schon groß passieren,
der Depp, dem das Video gehört, der kann ja einen Spruch einlegen.
Ja, so passiert es dann, haben wir ja auch gemacht.
So, bei der ersten Verwarnung, beim ersten Strike und beim zweiten Strike, also einer
hat es geflaggt, dann hat ein YouTube-Mitarbeiter sich das angeschaut, hat gesagt, ja gut, wird
schon stimmen, also ist jetzt gesperrt oder geflaggt und verwandt.
So, dann haben wir einen Spruch eingelegt, dann hat sich noch mal ein Mitarbeiter das
angeschaut.
Um jetzt mal ein aktuelles Beispiel aus dem Stream von heute zu bringen, das ist wirklich
viele, viele blöde Leute.
Nein, und ich meine übrigens nicht mit Leuten, mit denen ich ja gerade im Chat ein bisschen
diskutiert habe.
Ich glaube, ich glaube unterm Strich hat man dann verstanden, was ich meine.
Es gibt Leute, die würden sich das Video beispielsweise angucken, so das, was ich vorher
über den Twitter-Trump-Bun erzählt habe und wenn die sich diesen Ausschnitt angucken,
die würden dann überhaupt nicht drauf hören, sondern die wären gleich auf 180 und das ist
ein Punkt, der heute und gerade auf Social Media echt problematisch ist aus meiner Sicht,
dass Kritik gleich Beleidigung ist und dass die Leute daraus dann Schluss folgern, der
muss das ja gut finden.
Also sprich, wenn ich jetzt hier im Stream sage, dass ich den Trump-Bun auf Twitter aus
diesen und diesen Gründen nicht gut finde, ich habe zwar 50 mal dabei gesagt, dass es
mir um Trump nicht geht und dass es um den auch nicht schade ist und dass der viel Scheiße
erzählt hat, wenn der Tag lang ist, die Leute sagen dann, okay, Kritik gleich Beleidigung,
das muss ja Trump-Fan sein und der fand den gut, alter Disabo.
Wisst ihr was ich meine, die Leute sind so low-prane im Kopf, die können normale Gedankengänge
da nicht nachvollziehen.
Es gibt für die meisten Leute, gerade wenn du auf Twitter unterwegs bist, die verstehen
bloß noch Schwarz oder Weiß, so nach dem Motto, entweder du bewegst dich zu 100% im
Weltbild der jeweiligen Leute, dann bist du Freund und alles ist gut, sagst du irgendwas,
was da nicht ganz reinpasst, bist du der Teufel.
Das ist halt, ich weiß nicht, ob die Leute heute Probleme haben, so Zusammenhänge zu
verstehen, Sätze zu verstehen, Wörter zu verstehen, vielleicht mal nicht vom Allerschlimmsten
immer auszugehen, das ist wirklich hart und was unterm Strich war, was ich wirklich bedenklich
finde ist, dass Kritik gleich Beleidigung heutzutage ist, also bei vielen Plattformen,
guckt es euch an, wenn du zu irgendwas antwortest, zum Beispiel, es gab doch wieder die Diskussion,
ob man Böller-Böller-Verbot 2021-Hilfester war ja wieder Riesendiskussion auf Twitter
und da ging es dann darum, so nach dem Motto, wer nicht dafür ist, das zu verbieten, ist
automatisch, mindestens mal Umweltverschmutzer, Tierhasser, wenn nicht gleich Nazi oder sonstige
Geschichten, da war Instant Instant am Start wieder, und ich habe es gewagt auf Twitter
zu sagen, ich finde ein prinzipielles Verbot nicht gut, ich schreibe das ja mittlerweile
schon wirklich so, dass man das auch alles, zumindest wenn man ein bisschen Wörter, wenn
man ein bisschen den Zusammenhang von Sätzen versteht, nachvollziehen kann, ich persönlich
mache schon ewig kein Feuerwerk, aber ich habe geschrieben, ich finde es an sich nicht
gut, prinzipiell da jetzt pauschal zu sagen, man verbietet es, man sollte doch nach Alternativen
suchen, weil es ist selten irgendjemand damit geholfen mit direkt verboten, also alles verboten
und alles erlaubt, dazwischen gibt es noch eine riesen Zone, wo man Kompromisse finden
kann, also in der Regel ist es ja immer schlecht, wenn man sagt, man macht 0% oder man macht
100%, in vielen Bereichen sind wir auch so weit gekommen, weil es halt halbwegs sinnvolle
Kompromisse gibt, mit denen alle leben können, und da haben sich Leute wieder übelst darüber
aufgeregt, so nach dem Motto, von Umweltverschmutzung bis Tierhasser, ich meine, hat sich mal irgendeiner
mein Profil angeguckt, meint der wirklich, ich bin Tierhasser, jetzt allen Ernstes hat
man wirklich mein dritter Profil sich immer angeschaut, ich bin Tierhasser, ich habe da
so viele Bilder von meiner Katze drauf, Spenden ans Tier haben und alles, wer dann nur mal
zwei Minuten lang kommt, wie kommt der auf die Idee überhaupt, wie kommt der überhaupt
auf die Idee, aber nur weil ich es kritisiert habe, ist das für die Leute eine persönliche
Beleidigung, und letztendlich bin ich immer noch der Meinung, prinzipielle Verbote, also
dieses alles verbieten oder alles erlauben ist selten zielführend, man muss was in der
Mitte finden, was verträglich ist, zum Beispiel hätte man beim Böllern auch sagen können,
ok, im Anbetracht der Tatsache auch mit Corona und allem, sagt man die klassische Art und
Weise auf der Straße vielleicht nicht, aber keine Ahnung, auf einer Visa außerhalb oder
was auch immer, es gibt, es hätte 100.000 Lösungen gegeben, aber die Leute auf Twitter
haben nur akzeptiert, ich bin hundertprozentig dagegen, weil heute für viele Kritik gleich
Beleidigung ist.
Es ist auch schwierig, so einen YouTube Content Checker zu finden, der von der Technik Ahnung
hat, da sind ja wahrscheinlich irgendwelche unterbezahlten Leute, die jetzt nicht unbedingt
technisch noch großartiges Know-how haben, aber trotzdem halt überhaupt keine Ahnung
von der Materie, das ganze gipfelte dann da drin, was ich gesagt hatte, von wegen, dass
ein VPN Video, wie man einen VPN Server installiert, sowas wird in der Schule gezeigt, das kann
ja nicht gefährlich sein, Leute, wurde es bei euch, stimmt, es ging bei den Böllern
darum, dass die Leute nicht die Verletzten ins Krankenhaus, genau, und deswegen, da hätte
man sich ja mal Gedanken darüber machen können, ok, das ist ein valid Punkt, ergibt Sinn,
was kann man dagegen machen, hätte man vielleicht sich dazu, hätte man vielleicht eine Lösung
finden können, was weiß ich, dass man jetzt zentral das ganze macht, irgendwas, es hätte
garantiert eine sinnvolle Lösung gegeben zwischen komplett verboten und komplett erlaubt, gab
es ja im Endeffekt auch, gab es ja im Endeffekt auch, im Endeffekt kam raus, man darf das
alte zünden, aber kein neues kaufen, das war ja ein Kompromiss in gewisser Seite, war
es ja auch, aber das war nicht valid, da auch nur irgendwie Kompromisse vorzuschlagen,
aber trotzdem halt überhaupt keine Ahnung von der Materie, das ganze gipfelte dann da
drin, was ich gesagt hatte, von wegen, dass ein VPN Video, wie man einen VPN Server installiert,
sowas wird in der Schule gezeigt, das kann ja nicht gefährlich sein, wurde ernsthaft
bei euch in der Schule gezeigt, wie man einen VPN Server installiert, also es wäre sicherlich
nicht verkehrt, aber, ich mein, du kannst einen VPN Server nicht auf einem Overhead
Projektor betreiben, daran scheitert es ja schonmal.
Denn in der Schule würde nichts gezeigt werden, was gefährlich ist, worauf er dann eben wirklich
wörtlich antwortet, ja, also in seiner Schule hätten sie ihm nicht das Video gezeigt.
Was für eine bescheuerte Antwort, er wollte ihm damit doch sagen, dass er das, also dass
der Typ einfach keine, er wollte ihm quasi nett, auf nette Art und Weise sagen, dass
der Typ nicht das technische Know-How hat, um das Video zu bewerten.
Denn in der Schule würde nichts gezeigt werden, was gefährlich ist, worauf er dann
eben wirklich wörtlich antwortet, ja, also in seiner Schule hätten sie ihm nicht das
Video gezeigt, als wenn er dann sagen würde, damit wäre mein Argument ja Quatsch, mehr
oder weniger hat es mir nicht geglaubt, deswegen, der zweite Strike blieb dann bestehen, insoweit,
ja, also jetzt haben wir schon drei Leute oder zwei Leute, die sich das angeschaut haben,
keiner von denen hat Ahnung und deswegen kommt auch jeder zur falschen Einschätzung.
So natürlich jetzt auch mit dem dritten Strike, nur diesmal ist der ganze Kanal weg, die Twitter-Follower,
die machen Dampf, jetzt schaut sich nochmal ein Expertenteam das Video an, und jetzt guckt
halt mal einer drauf, der ein bisschen Ahnung hat, aber auch nur weil der Shitstorm am Start
war auf Twitter, und auf einmal war das Video wieder da, beziehungsweise der ganze Kanal
war wieder da.
Und das ist übrigens, das ist sowas, was ich beispielsweise cool finden würde, wenn
sowas verpflichtend wäre, du wirst denen das Hausrecht natürlich nicht absprechen
können, aber solche Sachen quasi vorgeschriebene Review-Prozesse, die auch nachvollziehbar
sein müssen, sowas, das wären, finde ich, gute Regeln für Social-Media-Sachen, dass
es irgendeine gewisse Verpflichtung zugibt, dass das nachvollziehbar sein muss und dass
du das halt auch tracken kannst, wie wo was entschieden wurde, weil ansonsten ist das
wie gesagt, der König hat gesprochen und so ist es jetzt.
Keinen dritten Strike mehr, und es gibt auch keinen Hinweis, welches Video denn überhaupt
zur Diskussion stand, das heißt wir können jetzt nicht sehen, was wurde da jetzt besprochen,
das ist dann offenbar auch gefährlich, können wir die Videos jetzt auch alle löschen, nein,
überhaupt keine Information, als wenn das ganze quasi nicht stattgefunden hätte.
Ja, also Chat, Chat, jetzt mal ernsthaft, es ist egal, welche Seite ihr nehmt, links,
oben, unten, auf dem Kopf oder was auch immer, die sind sich in vielen, also alle Extremisten
sind sich in vielen Punkten näher, als sie das eigentlich zugeben wollen.
Das heißt also jetzt im dritten Fall, ein Zuschauer hat das Ding geflägt, dann hat
sich ein YouTuber das angeschaut und hat gesagt, ok, von meinen Möglichkeiten, von wegen ich
entziehe die Monetarisierung, ich mach das Video FSK 18, oder die dritte Stufe, das Ding
ist so brutal, ich hatte auch mal ein Video, was war denn das nochmal, es war auch total
sinnlos, es war auf einmal ab 18, wegen Waffennutzung oder so, total wir, was war das denn, es war
auf einmal ab 18, ich hab keine Ahnung mehr warum, also weshalb wirklich es ab 18 war.
Es muss sofort gestrikt werden.
Ich glaube es war wegen Waffennutzung oder irgendetwas ganz merkwürdiges, hä?
Das Strike weiß ich ja nicht mal, ob der Mitarbeiter das überhaupt wusste, wahrscheinlich nicht,
das wird ja dann nachher quasi das System machen, von wegen, ok, der hat einen Strike
bekommen bei der dritten, also futsch.
Das heißt, da, dann hat sich der Experte das angeschaut und hat dann gesagt, nein, nein,
das ist weder super gefährlich, dass der Strike rechtfertigt ist, das ist auch nicht gefährlich,
das machen wir nicht, FSK 18, da erziehen wir nicht mal die Monetarisierung, weil wir
halt darüber überhaupt keine Nachrichten bekommen haben, dass irgendeines unserer Videos
jetzt 18 oder entmonetarisiert wurde, bei anderen Videos kriegen wir darüber eine Nachricht,
deswegen weiß ich das so genau.
Das heißt also, ja, der Pfleger hat sich vertan, der erste Experte hat sich vertan
und der zweite Experte in dem Fall, Einspruch hatten.
Da kann man sich halt mal fragen, wie viel Experten, also wie expertisch die Experten
eigentlich sind, ne?
Nicht eingelegt, weil wir gar nicht konnten, ja, so eine entgegengesetzte Meinung, innerhalb
von einem Laden.
Ja, ja.
Na gut, das wird so gewesen sein, das Video wurde irgendeinem Experte zur Durchsicht,
keine Ahnung, im indischen Uploadfilterbüro übergeben, der hat nur die Hälfte verstanden
wahrscheinlich, was er erzählt hat und haben gesagt, ich hab eh nicht so viel Ahnung davon,
das wird schon korrekt sein und dementsprechend block, der nächste Experte kam dann, keine
Ahnung, aus hier, vielleicht sogar mal aus dem deutschen Uploadfilterbüro, hat von der
Thematik auch keine Ahnung gehabt.
So und jetzt nach Twitter, wo die auf Twitter Action gemacht haben, wird halt mal jemand
geguckt haben, der ein bisschen Expertise hat und dann festgestellt, okay, ist wahrscheinlich
gar nichts dran.
Aber Experte ist ja eh so ein inflationärer Begriff, mittlerweile ist er ja Killerspiele-Experte,
genau.
Mittlerweile kannst du ja für alles Experte sein, ne?
Das wären dann Experten.
Ich hab heute Morgen ne Werbung bekommen auf YouTube, ne Coaching, so ein Coaching-Typ,
und das in dem Video, also so ne Werbung, da kam dann irgendwie, welcher Experte du 2021
werden musst, um irgendwie richtig durchzustarten.
Hallo, wird man jetzt jedes Jahr ein anderer Experte?
Experte bedeutet ja eigentlich, man hat Expertise, man hat Erfahrung, man hat Ahnung.
Es ist aber schwierig, Ahnung und Expertise zu haben, wenn jedes Jahr ein anderer Experte
ist.
Sebaro, so ist es ja.
Ich bin Experte für Experte-Seite.
Ja, weil es keine gibt.
Es gibt, okay, das stimmt nicht, es gibt welche, aber es gibt keine nennenswerte Alternative.
Das ist immer die gleiche, die Zuschauer, die kommen einfach nicht mit.
Ja.
Wir laden seit dem zweiten Strike alle Videos eben auch, zum Beispiel auf Dailymotion hoch
oder auf Meo.
Dailymotion, gibt's das noch, wie Meo, Alter.
Und deswegen haben wir jetzt hier auf sempervideo.de wieder aktiviert, eben um für die...
Moment, Freund.
Ich mein, guckt euch mal, guckt euch mal die Seite schon an, wie, wie, wie krack das
ist.
Hallo.
Wie viele Aufrufe hat das?
Man sieht euch mal, wie viele Aufrufe das hat.
Mein Gott.
... im Fall der Fälle gewappnet zu sein.
Klippfisch.
Aber machen wir uns nichts vor, die Zuschauer kommen im Grunde nicht mit.
Natürlich gibt's jetzt wieder einige, die sagen, ja, aber wir würden euch folgen und
so weiter.
Ist ja klar, ja, ganz sicher, aber der Großteil und damit weit über 90 Prozent, aber eben
nicht.
Man kann es den Zuschauer natürlich auch nicht verdenken, denn...
Nö.
Du kannst ja nicht auf 50 Plattformen rumgucken.
Und da sind wir wieder beim Punkt, man sieht, wie wichtig einzelne, wenige Plattformen
sind für so das, äh, so sagen wir, gesellschaftliche, soziale Miteinander 2021.
Und wenn da demnächst ein relativ unwichtiger Computerkanal fehlt, ist der nicht so, als
wenn das lebenswichtige Informationen sind, ja, dann interessiert das.
Der, warum er gebannt wurde, weiß man nicht.
Er hatte schon zwei Strikes und, tja.
Jetzt hat er einen dritten bekommen.
Ich meine, Fishing gibt es seit über zehn Jahren und genau so lange machen wir darüber
Videos, aber die hat keiner den Eindruck, als wenn es irgendwas bringen würde.
Keiner macht es mehr, der will ja nach, was in den Videos gesagt wird, um sich zu schützen
und ja, natürlich, es gibt einige, die machen das.
Ist ja auch gut so.
Irgendwie hört das ein bisschen angepisst an, was man auch verstehen kann.
Ja, übrigens, WhatsApp, WhatsApp ist auch ein super Ding.
Die Leute haben jetzt ja gesagt, oh nein, neue WhatsApp-Userbedingungen, wir gehen jetzt
zu Telegram, zu Signal, zu Discord und sonst was, oh nein, wir gehen jetzt, oh weg, WhatsApp,
oh.
Was meint ihr, wie es in einem halben Jahr aussieht?
Du wirst in dem Graph von WhatsApp, der Stonkscraft von WhatsApp, den die intern haben, wirst du
noch nicht mal einen kleinen Knick sehen.
Es wird absolut nichts anders sein.
Und da ist die Base natürlich auch, das würde was bringen, wie gesagt, geht aber nur als
Twitch-Partner, sind wir derzeit noch nicht, um Partner zu werden braucht man eine gewisse
Zahl von Zuschauern über einen gewissen Zeitraum, dann wird man Partner, das würde ich wahrscheinlich
glatt noch hinkriegen, allerdings, naja, das muss Livestreaming sein, da muss ich mir erst
noch was einfallen lassen, weil, na, dass ich demnächst AMA 3 streame, das sehe ich
jetzt noch nicht.
Na ja, ich bin gespannt.
Na ja, gut, er könnt seine Videos schon streamen, ja, da muss er halt live gehen, aber das geht
halt auf Twitch nicht so gut wie auf YouTube, weil auf Twitch kriegst du, ist jetzt live
und dann gehst du noch eine halbe Stunde später rein und dann ist er dann on, das ist nicht
wie auf YouTube, wo du dann ein Feed kriegst und weißt, du kannst jetzt ein fertiges Video
angucken.
Wenn der auf Twitch sein 14 Minuten Video live streamt, dann sind die ersten 5 Minuten
noch die Leute gar nicht da, also nee, das funktioniert nicht.
Fazit, danke nochmal an alle, die uns da geholfen haben, aber ich befürchte mal, das wird nicht
der letzte Kampf.
Ja, leider, leider.
Okay.
Echt problematisch.
So, wir gucken jetzt eine Runde Lockpicking an, das ist eine schwierige Frage, na ja,
ich finde das weder gut noch schlecht, ich hab da gar keine Meinung in Form von, ob ich
das gut oder schlecht finde, zu, es ist nachvollziehbar, weil die Leute eben Gewöhnungstiere sind
im Endeffekt, ja.
Die einfachste Variante, wie du Leute auf deine Plattform bringst, ist nicht etwa durch,
wir machen besseren Datenschutz oder so, ja, oder, oder solche Dinger, das ist denen vollkommen
egal.
Was du Leute auf deine Plattform bringst, ist, wir machen was einfacher, was du machen
willst, als die anderen, und zwar, musst du das so oft benutzen, und es muss so viel
einfacher sein, dass es die Hürde übersteigt, die den Plattformwechsel nach sich zieht,
und das gibt's halt bei WhatsApp einfach nicht für die 015 Benutzer.
Also deswegen kann ich nachvollziehen, ob ich das gut oder schlecht finde, ich find's
einfach nur logisch, ja.
Was ich allgemein schlecht finde, ist, dass es die meisten Leute halt absolut nicht interessiert.
Die meisten Leute wollen sich mit gewissen, sagen wir mal, mit Datenschutz-Thematiken
oder wie man sich sicher im Internet benötigt, die wollen sich, die wollen das gar nicht
wissen, weil, wenn man es wüsste, müsste man sich ja Gedanken drüber machen.
Also, ja, und das ist so ein Ding, da bin ich zu wenig Stonksmann für, ich persönlich
würde mich ja schon freuen, wenn es gerade für besonders bedeutende Social-, oder generell
für Social Media ein paar gesetzliche Vorgaben gäbe, die so dieses, der König hat entschieden
und fresst's ein bisschen einschränken könnte, ja.
Warum benutzen wir YouTube noch mal, da wir benutzen YouTube, weil es die größte Plattform
ist, und es keine nennenswerte andere Plattform in der Richtung gibt, zumindest in Europa
und, sagen wir mal, in der westlichen Welt.
Gibt's halt nicht, außerdem, jetzt mal unabhängig von diesen komischen Auslegungen der Regeln
auf, sagen wir mal, auf YouTube und auf Twitch, ich finde beide Plattformen nicht schlecht,
also Twitch finde ich durch die Bank weg, was die da technisch gemacht haben und wie
sich das entwickelt hat, auch seit der Übernahme, jetzt, wir reden ja mal rein von den Features
und der Plattform an sich, seit der Übernahme von Amazon, ist das, finde ich, nur besser
geworden.
Das, was schlechter geworden ist die letzten Jahre über, ist beispielsweise eben die willkürliche
Auslegung der Regeln, ja, gut, Twitch hat letztens ein paar Probleme, das stimmt, aber an sich
ist Twitch, finde ich, die beste Livestream-Plattform, die besten Features, da sind schon Leute,
die Ahnung haben, ja, also Twitch an sich ist super, ich muss auch sagen, bei YouTube
kann ich mich auch über viele Sachen beschweren, aber an sich ist YouTube auch nicht schlecht,
YouTube hat die letzten Jahre viele Dinge erkannt, die nicht gut waren, zum Beispiel
das View-Time mehr promoted wird als Clickbait, so nach dem Motto, also sprich, es ist wichtig,
dass du ein Video hoch, also wenn du ein Video hoch liest, was ne Stunde ist, Stunde lang
ist, die Leute gucken es 40 Minuten an, dass es eben auch gewisse Ranking gibt, nicht einfach
nur der Typ liest 14 Videos am Tag hoch und sowas, YouTube hat da schon viel erkannt,
deswegen werden in einem jetzt ja auch so viele längere Videos promoted und viele Channels,
die längere Videos machen, sind die letzten 2, 3 Jahre auch durch die Decke gegangen,
weil die jetzt zum ersten Mal richtig gefunden werden und bekannt gemacht werden, also ist
schon, Prime Sub ist auch eine super Geschichte, also an sich finde ich, dass YouTube und Twitch,
die machen die eigentliche Sache so gut, dass es für eine Alternative halt enorm schwer
ist, sich zu etablieren, weil die müssten ja irgendwas noch besser und einfacher machen
und das ist halt wirklich schwer, wie gesagt, rein mit Datenschutz schockst du die Leute
heutzutage nicht, es gab vieles, was ich früher auf YouTube besser fand, keine Frage, ja,
die Kanalseite zum Beispiel, dass es einen Inbox Private Message System gab, da gab es
schon viele Sachen, aber so für den normalen 0815 Zuschauer ist YouTube besser denn je
und Twitch auch und dementsprechend gehen auch alle Content-Creators dahin, weil wo
soll es sonst hingehen, ich weiß ein paar streamen auf Facebook Gaming, ein paar machen
TikTok Kram, TikTok ist auch nur so durch die Decke gegangen, weil es was anderes ist,
TikTok hat halt einfach was getroffen, was es so, wie sagt man, so streamlined noch nicht
gab, es gab diese Weingeschichte und so war es vorher alles, aber TikTok hat sich deswegen
durchgesetzt, dass in dieser Art und Weise für diese Zielgruppe, dieser Content, dieser,
wie sagt man so schön, Streamlined Experience, gab es halt vorher nicht, deswegen hat sich
der Kram ja auch durchgesetzt. Die Chinesen machen es anders, die Chinesen
machen einfach für alles ihren China-Klon, den du dann nutzen musst, weil alles andere
geploggt ist, das könnten wir auch machen, Leute, wir beleben Schüler und Studi-VOZ wieder
und sperren einfach Facebook, Instagram, Twitter und alles. Gute Idee, oder? Perfekt.
Ja, gibt's den? Erzhaft, gibt's das noch? Es sieht noch genauso scheiße aus wie früher.
Oh Mann, wie lang bin ich denn schon an? Wir haben relativ viele Videos geguckt und viel
geschwätzt. Kann man noch irgendwas, was wir schauen können?
Modded-Version, Snapchat, oh nee, das brauche ich jetzt nicht, haben wir schon mal geguckt.
Noch ein Lock, ja. Zeig. Okay, das hält genau 15 Sekunden bei ihm
wieder, dann hat er das auf. Was, Ironsides? Ach so, weil du da durchgucken
kannst, oder wie? Aber sobald man die Ironsides schon sieht,
ist es kein Quickscope mehr, da muss man aufpassen. Moritz, es gibt so viel Stuss,
den wir hier erfunden haben, um angeblich international Konkurrenz zu werden. Mein Lieblingsbeispiel
dafür ist immer noch, ich will jetzt nicht wieder mit Magenta Gaming oder so einem Schiss
ankommen, mein Lieblingsbeispiel ist immer noch Immer. Kennt ihr noch Immer? Weiß noch
jemand, was Immer ist? Kennt das noch jemand? Ja, mit 3M hat man das
glaube ich geschrieben. Das war eine WhatsApp Konkurrenz von der Telekom.
Da wurde schon vor Release sich drüber lustig gemacht, was die Telekom da für eine Scheiße
fabriziert und es hat halt nie, nie irgendjemand verwendet. Immer. Ja, da muss man sich News
angucken von. Guck mal, es gibt noch nicht mal Screenshots davon. Es gibt noch nicht
mal richtige Screenshots davon, so kacke war das und so wenig hat das jemand benutzt.
Hier immer Deutsche Telekom Start WhatsApp Konkurrent. Sieht ein bisschen aus wie Teams
für Arme. Die haben schon viel versucht, aber halt nichts richtig gemacht. Obwohl ich
mir schon vorstellen könnte, dass es Möglichkeiten gibt für einen deutschsprachigen Messenger
Dienst. Aber man muss sich halt überlegen, gerade in der heutigen Zeit, wo WhatsApp und
so sich schon so durchgesetzt hat. Was willst du da anders, besser, einfacher machen? Was
WhatsApp nicht schon hat und was die Leute brauchen? Also gar nicht, gar nicht so, gar
nicht so einfach. Du könntest es halt auf die Tour machen, dass du richtig viele deutsche
Server interessiert. Kein. Du hast vollkommen recht, aber es interessiert keinen. Frag den
0815 WhatsApp Benutzern mal, ob es ihnen stört, dass seine Daten auf in einem anderen Land
gespeichert werden. Na, was du machen könntest, ist, du könntest vielleicht Handys kostenlos,
Smartphone kostenlos verschenken. Oder irgendwas. Also ohne massiv viel Geld wird das nix. Wo
ist es denn? Letztes Video, was ich gucken wollte. Und spätestens, wenn das jeweilige
Wort stellvertretend für Kurznachricht geworden ist, wenn die Leute sagen, ich schreibe WhatsApp
oder sowas, oder das ist so wie, ich nehme Tempo, dann ist eh vorbei. Nutella ist ja auch
gleichbedeutend mit irgendeiner komischen Schokoladen-Nuss-Mischungscreme. Ja, also
das wird schwierig, da WhatsApp wieder rauszukriegen. Deswegen, Leute, wir müssen den Preischamp
als super Name etablieren, dass jeder nicht mal sagt, ich geh mal Preise vergleichen
oder so, sondern dass die Leute sagen, ich geh Preischampen. Das muss sein, der sagt,
ich geh Preischampen. Ich Preischampe. Preischamps du auch schon? Okay, er braucht wieder 10
Sekunden, bis es auf hat. Ich bin ein Preischamper, genau. Geil zahlst du doch oder Preischamps
du schon? Ja, sind da zwei komplett unterschiedliche Sachen. Geil zahls hat halt auch viel mehr
Sachen drinne und auch aus allen möglichen Produkten, das ist ja nicht ernsthaft. Es
ist eher eine gute Ergänzung zu Geil zahls. Pass mal auf, 5 Sekunden dauerts, 5 Sekunden
dauerts. Okay, 10 Sekunden. Okay, 10 Sekunden dauerts. Okay, 10 Sekunden dauerts. Okay,
10 Sekunden dauerts. Okay, der Typ zahlt echt drauf. Woher ziehst du die Preise von den
shopseiten
Leute ich sollte den preis champ live stream machen oder ich meine es gibt auf twitch es gibt stocktracker die sowas auf twitch machen
stocktracker
Da gucken einfach jetzt
175 leute zu wie das stocktracker trackt
Ich mache einfach den preis champ stream und dann zeige ich dann zeige ich einfach nur das
Aber im darkmode natürlich habt ihr übrigens gemerkt dass es jetzt einen darkmode gibt
Jojo ja das problem habe ich auch ich man kann es ein bisschen umgehen in dem man die timeout nicht die timeout zeiten die die
Wie heißt page page back up page timeout ich habe das hochgestellt dass der alles nur noch jede minute
Bis zu fünf minuten glaube ich crawlt weil es halt auch sehr viel ist ja aber wenn er halt in
Cloud protection hängt da kannst du nichts machen
Wie heißt deine seite hier betapunktpreischamp.org
Der darkmode passt sich aber nicht ans system an was soll das heißen
Der darkmode sieht überall gleich dark aus oder wie
Willst du jetzt etwa bestimmen wie dark auszusehen hat was ist hier los gleich gleich bin ich getriggert und bandig
Ich kann selbst bestimmen wie man darkmode aussieht
Was sagt oh es ist irgendwie kaputt
Oh es ist irgendwie kaputt
Ach darkmode eingestellt wird auch noch automatisch das ist ja das ist ja schon fast
Wie heißt wenn sich weiß als schwarz aus black facing alter
Wir müssen mal ein bisschen im aktuellen zeitgang sein ich muss mich jetzt über irgendwas empören aber du hast recht das wäre eine gute idee
Das wäre eine gute idee wenn es erkennt dass das der browser oder das system darkmode ist die sache ist nur die ich habe keine ahnung
wie man
Im browser erkennt ob das system darkmode hat das ist leider kein ref link ich bin ziemlich dumm dass ich da kein ref link hintendran machen
Warum kostet das fünf ach nee ich habe 5000 gelesen
Aber wenn ich den ref link mach brauche ich ein impressum
Da gibt es eine api wo gibt es eine api?
Wenn der kram innerhalb von zehn sekunden weg ist ja gut also
Wenn wirklich was da ist und einmal in der minute crawl nicht reicht dann
Aber man kann den kram nicht in der minute crawl machen
Pech ja aber man kann den crawler scale man könnte mehrere server
Ich mache ich mache impressum ich mache einfach einen about about page
Ich habe den impressum auf meinem youtube channel ich mache einfach die about page die impression mache ich auf meinen youtube channel das sollen sich
Im zweifelsfall bei meinem netzwerk melden die wissen dazu überhaupt nicht was sache ist aber gut ist
Es hier ist erst prefer color scheme das ist eine gute idee das mache ich
Oh cool das ist nice das baue ich ein dann hat man dann hat man standardmäßig dark dark theme wenn man
Ja
Sehr gut
Exzellent chat exzellent
Weißt das netzwerk noch dass du existierst die schicken wir jedes jeden monat eine abrechnung also
Gute frage wir auch egal
Hitman 3 ich wusste gar nicht dass hitman 3 gibt
Wir relauen mal youtube auch noch etwas gutes drauf ist was machen die überhaupt für dich es ist eine gute frage
Nicht so viel außer geld abbekommen
Die dark light mod knöpfe machen wir schon noch hin wobei ich überlege vielleicht lasse ich lasse ich so noch
Weil die meisten leute checken nicht dass man auf den keks klicken muss für dark light mod das ist ja eher solls easter egg gedacht
Warten wir mal ab
Ich muss den gar nichts abdrücken die bekommen halt wenn es was gibt immer einen gewissen share von ab
Heute baue ich übrigens noch wenn ich irgendwie zeit nicht hinkrieg dass die dass die dass die kraft stimmen
Also sprich der graf ist ja überall statisch und ich habe heute morgens schon der sql abfrage gebastelt ist nicht sonderlich schwer
um einfach für eine woche lang
Bekommst du wenig wenigstens regelmäßig sponsor angeboten von den nö ich bekomme von meinem netzwerk gar nix
Außer eine monatliche abrechnung die machen das im hintergrund dass man manchmal gewisse ads bekommt
Ansonsten keine ahnung ganz ehrlich eigentlich bräuchte wahrscheinlich kein netzwerk mehr
Ich habe übrigens eingestellt mittlerweile dass das nicht mehr so breit ups
Dass das nicht mehr so breit geht sondern nur noch ein bisschen breiter geht das nicht mehr so breit geht
Dass das nicht mehr so breit geht sondern nur noch maximal
Noch maximal so breit für drei
Bei vier wird es jetzt breiter oder
noch immer
Und ich habe es mir auf dem handy angeguckt ich muss sagen die seite sieht auf dem tablet mittlerweile richtig gut aus wisst ihr das
Das ist die darstellung auf dem ipad oder nehmen wir mal die die darstellung auf
Keine ahnung auf dem iphone
Das sieht richtig gut aus mittlerweile auch wenn man das hier aufmacht
richtig richtig responsive alles
Ja kann man hier runterscrollen wenn es mehr gibt und auf dem tablet auf dem tablet sieht es auch ziemlich gut aus
Gucken wir mal im tablet scale das auch richtig so nice
Agile responsive ist das
So was gucken wir uns jetzt noch mal an irgendwas haben wir doch bestimmt noch was uns youtube vorschlägt
Interessiert mich jetzt alles nicht so großartig wenn ich ehrlich bin
Also ich mache die adresse für max fps in meinem netzwerk hin ansonsten wahrscheinlich brauchst du kein impresso
Brauchst du nur eine impresso wenn du irgendwie was
Wenn das irgendwas geschäftliches ist
Aber dass die grenze ist halt relativ schnell erreicht
UVP von 1500 an der graf ist statisch
Deswegen habe ich ja da auch dahinter geschrieben in arbeit der graf ist überall der gleiche und statisch das hier unten funzt schon
Übrigens ich habe jetzt ich habe das hier jetzt auch bei mir lokal schon zentriert gemacht der text sieht besser aus wenn der text
Und die in der mitte ist
Ich habe ja auch eine org domain viel besser
8 euro cpu der billigste pc aus neubau ok ok wir haben schon mal ein video von ihm geguckt wo er irgendwie geschrieben hat der 1 euro pc
Und letztendlich war das nicht nicht falsch
Aber der hat einen euro pc aber 200 euro pc
Und dann hat er auch ein video von ihm geguckt wo er irgendwie geschrieben hat der 1 euro pc und letztendlich war das nicht nicht falsch
Aber der hat einen euro pc aber 200 euro benzin und fahrkosten verursacht
Das war nur so halb richtig
32 minuten das kannst du mir nachgucken
Es passt weil sinn macht das ganze hier nicht
Ja gut das ist ja nicht schlimm
Zurück zu einem neuen video von mir
Ja gut wir fangen damit an wir haben hier einfach nur ein pc gehäuse
Aero cool cs103 die günstigste
Ok das eigentliche video was uns interessiert geht geht im prinzip nur bis hier so hin
Das können wir uns mal kurz angucken
Der Rest ist egal
Der Rest zappen wir mal durch
Also 8 euro cpu also wie viel hat es gekostet
Kommt von mtech
Und mtech ist mir eigentlich eher ein begriff als
Hab ich noch nie gehört
Was ist mtech
Das ist nämlich hersteller von diverser chemie und tonbänder
Hab ich noch nie gehört
Sieht eher aus wie aliexpress ssd
Arbeitsspeicher nehmen wir hier einfach nur ganz normal 4 gigabyte
Ich hab den jetzt nicht bestellt weil ich den schon hier habe und ich berechne einfach nur den preis dafür mit
Genauso wie diese 2 euro blar
Für ein sata kabel
Kann man das m kompletten dann
Was ich mit bestellen wollte was wir eigentlich nicht brauchen
Das mainboard hier haben wir nämlich
Und ja ich erzähle gleich ein bisschen mehr dazu
Das kam wirklich so verpackt an
Es ist aber neu
Na ja für einen euro
Gucke mal klingelt da nicht die alarmglocken oder
Was denn das
Was
Ich erkenne gar nicht was
Ok da ist ein ganzer pizzi
Ah ne ne 3 pizzi express so schlecht ist das doch gar nicht
Was ist ein x79
Mainboard
Was x79
Was ist ein x79 für eine plattform amd
Ich kann mir das nicht merken
Ich bin da komplett raus
Das sind zur cpu
Damit fing ja eigentlich alles an
Das ist nämlich ein intel xeon
Ok
E5 2620
Der braucht nur ordentliche kühlung
Ja das stimmt
Aber wir wollten ja dafür den günstigsten
Also schon ein paar jahre alt
LC power
Oh nein LC power
Wupp smoke
LC power
Die machen auch billig china netzteile
Ist wirklich kurz vor dem abfackeln
Ccc 120
Als vorletztes haben wir dann dieses
LC power netzteile
Das ist nur noch neu möchte ich behaupten
Ich meine so ein kabelbinder kann sie hier drum packen
Aber das sieht jetzt nicht übermäßig dreckig aus
Es riecht auch nicht so
Und für mich ist irgendwas auch noch neu
Wenn es einmal ausgepackt wurde
Nur damit es getestet werden kann
Besser vor dem versenden einmal auspacken und dann feststellen
Oh das Ding funktioniert ja gar nicht
Als einfach irgendwas rauszuschütteln
Und dann zu sagen
Ja das wusste ich ja nicht
Ja ok leider ist es nun so
Weil die grafikkarte immer noch nicht angekommen ist
Bei ebay steht zwar eine sendungsnummer drin
Aber das paket wurde noch nicht abgegeben
Wisst ihr warum ich den channel mag
Ich guck den auch ab und zu mal
Der hört sich immer so ein bisschen
So ein bisschen halb bekifft
Ultra entspannt an
Das finde ich cool
Es gibt so viele channels mittlerweile auf youtube
Die so hyper aktiv sind
Und der hört sich so ein bisschen nach vape nation an
Ich guck dir gern
Werd ich gleich auch noch zeigen
Welche das ist
Die ist nicht übermäßig gut
Deswegen verwenden wir dieses Teil
Kennen wir aus dem 2. oder 3. 0 Euro PC Video
Und falls die gar nicht erkannt wird
Weil die einfach uralt ist
Nehmen wir diese GT 710
Es ist nur so ich habe heute Zeit
Morgen nicht mehr, übermorgen nicht mehr
Die grafikkarte ist ja auch schon antik
Sehe ich dann einen VGA und einen S-Video Ausgang
Wo findet man sowas überhaupt noch
Deswegen mache ich es besser jetzt fertig
Und baue dann später noch die grafikkarte um
Da war Kobold noch neu
Da werden sowieso keine großartigen Sprünge
Gegenüber dieser Karte herrschen
Um euch jetzt aber mein Mindset ein wenig näher zu bringen
Zeige ich euch einfach mal die anderen
Mindset war das nicht erstmal die Belschnicks machen
Wer gedacht habe, dass es irgendwie passt
Es kommt auch noch dazu
Dass man wirklich am selben Tag wo ich geguckt habe
Und wahrscheinlich auch zur selben Stunde
Hätte gucken müssen
Ob das jetzt wirklich das aller billigste war
Was es da so gab, deswegen müsste mir vertrauen
Es sei denn die jeweiligen anderen
Trust ist raus
Zum Beispiel Gehäuse passt nicht
Ich verschwinde jetzt mal hier in diese Ecke
Damit ich die Annoncen hier reinsetzen kann
Also ich habe ja nach Prozess für 11 Euro gekriegt
Ist ja erstmal gar nicht so schlecht
Aber dann muss ich natürlich gucken
Versand
Ok kostet ja mal 3 Euro Versand
Die sind ein bisschen teurer
Aber es muss ja auch ein Neuteil sein
Aber es gibt ja ziemlich diese China Dinger
Und da habe ich dann dieses Exemplar hier gefunden
Ursprünglich 74,99
Ich habe aber
71,99 Euro bezahlt
Ein Schnapper
Dafür
Dafür kriegst du ja fast schon
Ok nicht die gleiche
CPU Leistung
Dann kriegst du schon eine aktuelle Low Power Intel Plattform
Aber natürlich beweite mich die Leistung
Natürlich schön, ich weiß
Dann muss es noch ein Kühler sein
Es war erst ein anderer Kühler
Quasi in
Aussicht
LC Power CC 120
Hat nicht 100%ig gepasst
Ich weiß es nicht mehr
Wieder die Heatpipes einfach
Direkt durch die Palade durchgehen
Mit diesem Kühler hier von
LC Power LCCC 120
Mir ist gerade übrigens nochmal eingefallen
Warum ich den Kühler unbedingt haben wollte
Weil da nämlich dabei stand
Bei der Hersteller Seite
Das Wärmeleitpaste dabei ist
Das Wärmeleitpaste zu kaufen wäre im Vergleich zu dem anderen
Ein bisschen teurer gewesen
Genauso war es auch mit Netzteil und Gehäuse
Man kann ja auch Netzteile fertig kaufen
Mit einem Gehäuse dabei
Auf 15,2 Millimeter
Der Computer Kramer
Alter
Das ist ja schon
Antik
Geforce 6200
Ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen
Das ist so alt
Dass wir in zwei Grafikkarten Generationen schon wieder
Bei der Numerierung angekommen sind
Wir sind aktuell schon wieder
Bei 3090
In zwei Grafikkarten Generationen sind wir wieder
Bei 6000
In drei
Ich habe die Ausgabe mal vorgestellt
Und da wird quasi der Arbeitsspeicher mitgenutzt
Für den Videospieler
Das Ding ist absolute Fratze
Gut ausgedrückt
Absoluter Crap
Ach mit TurboCache ist gemeint
Nicht etwa was Gutes
Sondern das ist kein eigenes RAM
Dass er keinen eigenen RAM drauf hat
TurboCache klingt wie was Gutes
In Wirklichkeit ist TurboCache was Schlechtes
2006, 15 Jahre
Wäre die in Benutzung gewesen
Sehe dir auf jeden Fall ganz anders aus
Da musste ich noch schauen, okay
Netzteil, dann nehme ich einfach irgendeins was am billigsten ist
Und das ist dann auch
LC Power
Bei LC Power
Hätte ich ja schon überhaupt keine Bedenken
Unbeaufsichtig laufen zu lassen
Ich habe genau dasselbe
Also hätte ich das gar nicht bestellen müssen
Weil es dann ja eigentlich das gleiche gewesen wäre
Zumindest habe ich dann etwas funktionierendes hier
Und wenn man etwas neu kauft, dann erwartet man das natürlich auch
Ist ja klar
SSD war einfach diese hier, ich fand den Namen interessant
War das günstigste was man kriegen kann
Ist eine SSD, was willst du sonst noch darüber erzählen
Was ich dann leider noch vergast
War einfach nur irgendein SATA Kabel
Hier das billigste für 2 Euro Blah
Als Neuteil
Versandkostlos, das kann doch nur aus China kommen, oder?
Versandkostlos für
2,19
Einmal 4 GB DDR3
1333 Megahertz
Für 13,99
Damit ich wohl alles durch
Und mir fällt gerade auf
Ja, wunderschön
Artikel Standort Chemnitz
Ach, als interessiert es die Chinesen, ob das wirklich stimmt
Was da steht
Meine Windows-Startleiste unten links im Bild
Funktioniert nicht mehr
Der AliExpressseller hat einfach irgendeine deutsche Stadt ausgewählt
Aus dem Dropdown
Hoffentlich in und auswendig, wir wissen die Grafik
Halt es noch nicht da, vielleicht kommt sie gar nicht
Spannend
Das skippen wir mal ein bisschen vor
Ich weiß zwar nicht so genau
Was er dann damit machen will, aber
An sich ist die Idee
Gar nicht so blöd, den billigsten ebay PC zusammenzubauen
Um zu gucken, was geht
Das eventuell
Sogar klappen
Das Gehäuse sieht ja gar nicht mal so extrem
Reudig aus
Warum machen Hersteller das und lassen hier die erste
Spalte weg
Für doppelt hohe Grafikkarten
Weil die zu faul sind, da einen zweiten Slot zu machen
Es gibt zwar ein paar Mainboards
So wie eventuell dieses hier
Die direkt auf dem ersten Slot schon den
Grafikkartenslot sitzen haben
Aber natürlich noch längst nicht alle
Als nächstes der Low-end ebay
PC-Cluster
Mit Kubernetes
Und dann werden die Pots
Gescaled, Leute
Damit gescaled, was das Zeug hält
Man muss nur richtig skalieren
Diese Teile
Die sind dazu da, um rausgeprokelt zu werden
Die sind nur an zwei kleinen Stellen fest
Schön zu sehen ist allerdings, dass hier
Ein Gehäuse-Lüfter dabei ist
Ich weiß nicht, wie laut der ist, aber da ist leider ein 3-Pin-Anschluss
Der Grafikkarten von 2006
In diesem Mainboard glaube ich nur zwei
Lüfteranschlüsse haben, nämlich einmal für den CPU-Lüfter
Und einmal für irgendeinen
Gehäuse-Lüfter
Und dass da auch noch ein 4-Pin-Anschluss ist, möchte ich behaupten, dass
Der die ganze Zeit auf 12 Volt läuft
Das heißt, es wird auch keinen Unterschied machen
Thrope, Björn, du hast das
Overwatch-League-Logo
Guckst du noch Overwatch auf YouTube?
Mich interessiert, ob ich irgendjemand finde, der wirklich noch
YouTube Overwatch guckt, generell der Overwatch guckt
Also ich gucke ja auch schon ewig nicht mehr
Und spätestens, also ich habe
Ich habe eh schon nicht mehr viel geguckt
Aber als das auf YouTube umgezogen ist
Habe ich von heute auf morgen komplett aufgehört
Alter, Blizzard hat es so
Krass verschissen, das ist der Wahnsinn
Wie viel CUDA-Core hat die CPU?
Wenn du in der Firmware nach CUDA
Grabs, wirst du feststellen
Du wirst
Noch nicht mal diese Zeichenfolge irgendwo finden
Trick 17
Ist der beste Trick, den verwend ich auch auf das
In einem Monat ist
Warum ist BlizzCon denn im
Im Februar?
Hä?
Okay, wir skippen mal vor
Erstes Einschalten in neue Grafiker
Mich interessiert mal, was die da
Style-Synbench, genau
Hallo
Okay
Wie viel CPU?
6 Cores?
Ja, sooo
Scheiße ist das jetzt gar nicht
Man, das ist da nicht
Richtig, aber sooo schlecht
Ist das gar nicht
Und ich meine, so knapp
600 Cinebench R15 Punkte
Das sind so die Werte, mit denen
Ich in meinem Kopf immer ein bisschen arbeite
Ist jetzt nicht so überragend hoch
Aber auf jeden Fall besser, als so
Manch andere
Ich habe mal nachgeschaut, der billigste
Celeron, den man heutzutage kaufen kann
Also einzeln
Der hat glaube ich 200 Punkte oder so was
220 und die Generation davor
Ein paar Punkte weniger
Hab ich sogar hier
Also ich habe ja mal einen Mining Rig geschenkt bekommen
Mainboards nicht
Und explizit standen
Okay, ein Driver-CD wird ja nicht unbedingt als
Goody ansehen im Jahr 2021
Keine Bedienungsanleitung dazu gibt
Aber es gab eine dazu
Driver-CD stand glaube ich drin
Gibt es dazu, ja
Vor allem Driver-CD, warum machen die nicht eigentlich mal
Mittlerweile ein Driver-USB Stick dabei
Na gut, weil es teurer ist
Theoretisch die 2 oder 3 Euro, was das da waren
Jetzt kann er
Verkaufen, jetzt kann das Ding wieder auf jeden Fall verkaufen
Top Gaming PC 2021
Und
Wenn man diese Plastik Pins, die da drin waren
Also
Sonenlüfter, die kosten
Wahrscheinlich
Aber alles in allem kannst du wirklich von der 10 Euro
CPU natürlich nicht übermäßig viel
Erwarten und es würde
Wie viel hat es jetzt insgesamt gekostet?
190?
Hab ich das nicht aufgepasst? Wie viel hat er insgesamt bezahlt?
190 oder so, ha?
Theoretisch die 2 oder 3 Euro, was das da waren
Stimmt, kein RGB
Hätte er RGB gehabt, dann wäre er ein paar tausend
Signbench
Wie spricht man das überhaupt aus?
Es wird ja nicht Cinebench sein
Cinebench
Echt?
Cinebench? Wirklich?
Cinebench
Cinebench, okay
Also nicht Cine, Cinebench
Alles klar
Hier lernt man noch was, Chat
So, gibt nichts Gescheites mehr, was uns YouTube empfiehlt
Und ich hab Hunger
Ach, das ist dieses Oracle Video
Das haben wir uns schonmal angeguckt, richtig fail
Also Leute, denkt dran, wir müssen Preischampen
unbedingt als Wort durch etablieren
Also immer, immer
wenn ihr jetzt irgendwie Preisvergleich
macht oder nachguckt, ob was
lieferbar ist, dann Pricechamp
Dann Pricechamp ihr einfach
Nachher Preischamp
Ja, mal gucken, mal gucken
Ich wollte eigentlich mit dem M-Core noch was aufnehmen heute, mal gucken, aber Zeit an
Wir sind noch mal auf opin
Wer ist denn on?
Zeig mal her
Da gibts eh schon einen, dem wir hausten können
haben wir
irgendjemand am Start
Wer ist da am Start?
Der Frazier? Ist der Frazier auf?
Leute, der Frazier, nice, alles klar, wir raiden jetzt den Friseur
Raid, excellent, M-Core gibt's noch, ja, lass mal den Friseur raiden, Twitch
I-Frizi, da ist er, irgendwelche, ah, vor einer Woche hat er noch erzählt er gibt nichts mehr im
Online Shop aus, das ist keine Copyright Musik, das ist Game Musik, die kann man noch nehmen zum
größten Teil, er hat bestimmt, er hat bestimmt reingecashed wieder schon, also Leute macht's
gut, ich hau ab, wir sehen uns, bis denn, CU, vielleicht am Mittag schon wieder